wir setzen jetzt die aussprache zur
vereinbarten debatte zur politik der
bundesregierung fort ich erinnere daran
dass wir gestern für die heutige
aussprache neun stunden und 19 minuten
insgesamt beschlossen haben wir beginnen
mit den bereichen wirtschaft und
klimaschutz für die aussprache zu diesem
themenbereich ist eine dauer von 90
minuten vorgesehen
das wort hat jetzt der bundesminister dr
robert habeck
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren ist für mich eine besondere ehre
meine erste rede in diesem hohen haus
auch noch gleich mit einer
regierungserklärung zu beginn gibt quasi
keine rhetorische warmen laufzeit und
das ist eigentlich ein ganz gutes bild
für das was für die arbeit in meinem
haus ansteht auch da werden wir wenig
zeit uns erstmal eingewöhnen zu haben
sondern wir müssen gleich sofort
loslegen wir als land wie als
gesellschaft müssten sofort loslegen
wird hätten diese regierungs diese
regierung in einer phase von großer
veränderung an eine veränderung die man
überall im alltag spürt und die
verschiedene gründe hat und diese
verschiedenen gründe und ursachen
bündeln sich auch in meinem haus auch in
den häusern von anderen kolleginnen und
kollegen aber sicherlich auch im bereich
des wirtschafts- und klimaschutz
ministeriums in besonderem maße
natürlich ist es die korona krise als
allererste große aufgabe die zu
bewältigen ist nach wie vor und
aufbauend auf der arbeit meiner
vorgänger meines vorgängers peter
altmaier ist es wieder gelungen mit den
überbrückungshilfen vier den unternehmen
zumindestens die zeit bis die krise
wieder normales wirtschaften erlaubt zu
bestehen zu schaffen mehr als zeit
schaffen ist es allerdings nicht denn
die finanziellen brocken der unternehmen
werden immer dürftiger die gewinne
werden in vielen bereichen geringer und
die
investitionstätigkeiten lassen nach
trotzdem bin ich froh und auch ein
bisschen stolz auf die kolleginnen und
kollegen die das gemacht haben diese
programmierung leistet ja nicht der
minister sondern
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter die
zwischen den weihnachts und neujahrs
tagen er sonderschichten gezogen
geschoben haben dass wir es geschafft
haben noch vor dem mpk beschluss die
programmierung abzuschließen das war
davor auch noch nicht möglich das heißt
die unternehmen die überbrückungshilfen
haben wollten konnten gleich mit dem
beschluss die anträge stellen eine große
leistung des hauses team wirklich war
nur möglich war weil es ein gut
eingespieltes team auch in der
vorgängerregierung gegebenheit auf dass
sich aufbauen konnte aber es endet
natürlich nicht bei der korona pandemie
ich glaube die herausforderungen zu groß
und jetzt alle in den neun minuten sex
habe ich noch oder sieben die mir
gegeben sind auf zu ziehen oder in der
tiefe zu bearbeiten
aber wir erleben eine globale
veränderung der weltwirtschaft
ablesbar an dem hunger nach fossilen
energien die die preise für die
unternehmen aber auch für die
verbraucherinnen und für die verbraucher
im moment nach oben treiben und wichtig
bei dieser debatte die wir im moment ja
tagein tagaus führen ist festzuhalten
dass der hunger nach fossilen energien
ist die die preise nach oben treiben gas
öl kohle das ist das was die preise im
moment treibt die maßnahmen die wir
ergreifen kurzfristig sind dann zur
entlastung der verbraucher der
verbraucher die abschaffung der eeg
umlage der bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat
es gestern in der befragung noch einmal
ausgeführt und auch eine faire umlage
der co2 kosten zwischen mietern und
vermietern die arbeiten daran haben
begonnen
mittelfristig
möglichst richtig
ist die beste chance die wir haben und
die beste strategie auf die wir uns
konzentrieren sollten uns unabhängig zu
machen von den fossilen energien
das gebietet der klimaschutz und die
aufgaben die damit verbunden sind auch
die ökonomischen und die
gesellschaftlichen kosten die immer
höher werden es gebietet aber auch das
nutzen der innovationspotenziale der
deutschen wirtschaft ja man kann es auch
als große bedrohung als zumutung
beschreiben und ich habe das in den
letzten tagen auch getan aber in
wahrheit ist es auch eine
herausforderung die uns wachsen lassen
kann und zwar buchstäblich wachsen
lassen kann den wohlstand und den
reichtum dieses landes auch den
ökonomischen reichtum noch einmal zu
hebeln und uns trotzdem unabhängig zu
machen von roche oder unabhängiger zu
machen von rohstoffimporten
durchgeschlafen geschlossene kreisläufe
eine neue form des wirtschaftens und die
co2 emissionen zu senken wenn wir das
wenn wir das
wenn wir das schaffen in der zeit die
uns bleibt
gemessen an den co2 budgets auf die wir
als völkerrechtlich verpflichtet haben
aber auch gemessen an der globalen
konkurrenz situation denken sie an
elektrische mobilität denken sie an den
hunger von rohstoffen der anderen länder
die auch alle sehen werden wie sie in
die neue infrastruktur aufbauen wie sie
auf wasserstoff setzen werden dann
drängt die zeit und wenn man sich
anschaut wie im moment die planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren sind merkt man
dass die rechnung einfach so nicht
aufgeht wir haben bis 2030 uns gegeben
die co2 emissionen um 65 prozent zu
senken das sind ist ein konsens
beschluss weit in diesem haus sind die
ziele der letzten in der letzten
regierung und wie er als ampelkoalition
haben sie übernommen es müsste also
konsens in großen teilen dieses hauses
bestehen dass die mittel dafür jetzt
auch ergriffen werden heißt also - 65
prozent co2 emission in acht jahren die
durchschnittliche genehmigungs zeit für
eine windkraftanlage in deutschland
beträgt sechs bis acht jahre da muss man
jetzt nicht besonders helle sein und
einen mathematik in der schule aufgebaut
haben und zu merken dass das nicht
funktionieren kann wir müssen also
effizienter und schneller werden in den
planungs in den genehmigungsverfahren
wenn die elektrifizierung einer schiene
40 jahre dauert ein radweg zu planung
sogar zehn jahre dauert dann kann das
nicht ausreichend sein wir müssen besser
werden wir müssen noch mal neu ansetzen
und schweller bleiben
thyssenkrupp will und die anderen
stahlunternehmen auch wollen umstellen
auf co2 freie produktion alleine für
thyssenkrupp und die andere unternehmen
werden ist mir nachsehen dass ich die
zahlen ist hier nicht referieren wird
dafür in der im endstadium ein
wasserstoff volumen von 30
terawattstunden gebraucht das ist das
zweieinhalbfache des stromverbrauchs von
berlin nur für ein unternehmen für ein
standort und wir haben der wahrlich
viele in deutschland und die der rest
der grundstoffindustrie ist damit noch
gar nicht benannt wir werden also mit
einem großen rollout auch von
elektrisieren in deutschland eine neue
infrastruktur aufbauen müssen die müssen
gefertigt werden die induktionsöfen
müssen gebaut werden wir stehen also
wenn wir es richtig angehen vor einer
großen phase des industriellen und das
ist dann ein mittelstands durch die
zulieferindustrie und ein handwerks
aufschwung in deutschland ja man kann
darüber klagen die schwer alles ist und
wie groß die herausforderungen sind und
wie sehr wir in rückenlage anfangen ich
will das nicht mehr tun ich sehe die
chancen für die deutsche wirtschaft ich
sehe die chance für wachstum und
klimaschutz das sich wunderbar ergänzen
kann wenn wir denn besser effizienter
produktiver werden in der verwaltung und
in der
hier ist
mir ist vollends klar dass das nicht
eine partei eine regierung machen kann
wir werden auch im zusammenspiel der
verschiedenen staatlichen gewalten
träger der parlamente der länder der
bundesregierung der ressorts
untereinander zu einem neuen verständnis
kommen müssen dass wir kooperativ
arbeiten und nicht in konkurrenz uns das
schwarze unterliegen nicht gönnen wir
gucken alle wir sind auch politiker
immer wieder auf die nächste wahl aber
am besten wäre es wenn die gewinnen
würden die die besten konzepte am
schnellsten umsetzen und nicht den
anderen das leben möglichst schwer
machen so will ich die arbeit führen für
billig bekommt kollegen zusammenarbeiten
so will ich auf die ministerpräsidenten
und die kolleginnen und kollegen in den
wirtschafts- und energie ressorts zu
gehen wir müssen wenn es ein konsens
über die ziele gibt wenn wir die chancen
für die deutsche wirtschaft und damit
für die deutsche gesellschaft in arbeit
und beschäftigung sehen wir müssen es
schaffen diese acht jahre möglichst
effizient zu nutzen und in diesen vier
jahren möglichst weit zu kommen ich
jedenfalls freue mich auf die gemeinsame
zusammenarbeit in vielen dank dass sich
hier vorstellen durfte
robert habeck dass bundesminister für
wirtschaft und klimaschutz in seiner
ersten rede in dieser legislaturperiode
im bundestag gleich eine kleine
regierungserklärung und wie es die
geschäftsordnung des bundestages
eigentlich von allen verlangt
freigehalten hat betont nächste riemann
schutz ist eine gemeinschaftsaufgabe von
bund und länder und allen parteien
nächste rednerin beziehungsweise erste
gegen rednerin die frühere
bundesministerin für ernährung und
landwirtschaft jetzt fraktions vize der
unionsfraktion julia klöckner
guten morgen zusammen frau präsidentin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sehr
geehrter herr bundesminister für ihr
neues amt wünsche ich ihnen viel elan
gute entscheidungen und den blick für
das große ganze aber auch für das kleine
wird das konkret für das
alltagspraktische was ihr heute in ihrer
rede doch etwa zu kurz gekommen ist wir
bieten ihnen als opposition eine
konstruktive eine kritische begleitung
an wir werden das unterstützen was wir
für vernünftig halten aber eigene
vorschläge machen wo wir besseres
erwarten
wirtschaftsminister sie möchten den
turbo an waffen für den klimaschutz und
für die wirtschaft wie vielen
familienunternehmen auch die
industriebetriebe mit ihren zahlreichen
arbeitsplätzen die erwarten von einem
wirtschaftsminister einen fürsprecher
sie warten erwarten von einem
wirtschaftsminister einen anwalt der
ihre themen auch nach vorne bringt aber
es ist schon bemerkenswert für einen
wirtschaftsminister dass ihnen
unternehmertum eigenverantwortung und
wettbewerb eher lästig sind denn in
ihrer rede war davon überhaupt kein wort
zu hören und deshalb sehr geehrter
wirtschaftsminister wo
wirtschaftsminister drauf steht muss
auch wirtschaftsminister drin sein
und wenn sie dann doch über wirtschaft
sprechen dann kündigen sie an ihrem
ministerium
transformieren die wirtschaft ich möchte
aber klarstellen nicht sie
transformieren die wirtschaft mache der
transformation sind die über die sie
leider fehlt so die nicht gesprochen
haben die unternehmer die erfinder die
gründe und deshalb grüne planwirtschaft
die wird nicht funktionieren
und in diesen monaten
unternehmer zu sein oder
unternehmerinnen zu sagen das ist ja
nicht immer ein vergnügen selbstständige
lösen ihre altersversorgung aufstecken
es in betriebe und arbeitsplätze um sie
zu retten und an dieser stelle möchte
ich all denen danken die in dieser
schwierigen zeit durchhalten das ist
unternehmertum denn von unterlassen
kommt unser land nicht voran
und wer glaubt mit der krone den hätte
er schon genug zu schultern
der kämpft nun auch mit steigenden
energie und lohnnebenkosten mit
lieferengpässen ich muss auch ein
bisschen es ist schon interessant dass
die grünen an der stelle wo es darum
geht dass selbstständige ihre
altersversorgung die bei uns gut
geregelt ist als abgeordnete aber das
selbstständige ihre altersversorgung
auflösen um arbeitsplätze zu retten das
in der nichts anderes einfällt als zu
lachen deshalb fehlt das zeigt dass
wirtschaft für sie überhaupt keine rolle
hier auch spielt energie und
lohnnebenkosten steigen lieferengpässe
preis explosion fachkräftemangel oder
schauen wir auf die schlüsselindustrie
hunderttausende von arbeitsplätzen
wurden in deutschland vor krone noch 5
millionen autos gebaut sind es jetzt 3
millionen einen
bundeswirtschaftsminister muss das und
treiben das darf ihm keine ruhe lassen
und deshalb erwarten wir von ihnen habe
ich ja ein turbo für klimaschutz aber
bitte auch ein turbo für die
wirtschaftspolitik und statur wo sind
sie gestern erst mal auf die bremse
getreten im café mädchen was haben sie
gemacht die bürokratie entlastung
stichwort normenkontrollrat der wurde
jetzt aus dem kanzleramt verband früher
chef sache jetzt unter ferner liefen und
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen neben
diesen aktuellen herausforderungen
werden uns auch langfristig
ja auch strukturelle herausforderungen
beschäftigen klimaschutz energie und
emissionshandel wird nachher mein
kollege andreas jungen ansprechen ich
bin mir sicher ohne eine
weiterentwicklung unserer sozialen
marktwirtschaft
zu einer digitalen
nachhaltigen sozialen marktwirtschaft
wird es nicht gehen und wirtschaft staat
und gesellschaft benötigen hierfür einen
digitalisierungs puste noch mehr
regulierung das wäre gift wir brauchen
hier and fest freiraum für innovationen
deshalb sehr geehrter herr herr beck wir
brauchen experimentier räume für
leuchtturmprojekte
und die neue bundesregierung ist er
angetreten um die digitale kompetenzen
zu bündeln sie wollten ein zeichen
setzen sie setzen ein zeichen habe ja
aber das falsche denn sie geben
digitalisierungs kompetenzen aus ihrem
haus abgehalten die fördertöpfe von
bündelung ist da wenig zu spüren und als
union haben wir bereits wichtige
maßnahmen angestoßen des online zugangs
gesetz basis register unternehmer konto
und deshalb sage ich einfach umsetzen
ohne zu zögern das hilft der wirtschaft
aber was machen sie sie entlassen erst
einmal viele wirtschaftspolitischen
sachverstand in ihrem ministerium fünf
oder sechs abteilungsleiter mussten
gehen stadtwirtschaft wirtschaftsexperte
setzen sie auf ngo ideologie sie haben
einen staatssekretär ist der gründer von
attac mit ist es ist durchaus
bemerkenswert steht auf der homepage
zitat ziel muss sein die produktion von
nicht benötigten gütern auszusetzen und
wer bestimmt was benötigt wird sie im
ministerium
ihre größte wirtschaftspolitische
schlagzeile war bisher das ende des
wachstums einzuleiten
das gilt jetzt nun nicht für den zuwachs
ihrer mitarbeiter stellen im ministerium
das haben wir gemerkt ein nachhaltiges
umsichtiges wirtschaftswachstum ist
innovations- und wohlstands treiber und
voraussetzung für transformation in
meinem wahlkreis zb in idar oberstein in
einer eher strukturschwachen region baut
sonntag hunderte von arbeitsplätzen auf
und warum weil dieses unternehmen wächst
und das ist auch gut so und deshalb sehr
geehrter herr beck machen sie
wirtschaftspolitik zur chefsache bringen
sie der wirtschaft mehr wertschätzung
entgegen und wenn wir uns anschauen
stichwort corona krise geht tief in
dieses wirtschaften großer teile unserer
unternehmen herein wir brauchen ein
sofortprogramm für unseren standort und
für die wirtschaft und im
koalitionsvertrag der ampel finden sich
durchaus ansatzpunkte dazu jährige noch
weiter neun punkte bessere
abschreibungsmöglichkeiten kaum mehr
steuerliche verlustverrechnung müssen
ausgeweitet werden verkürzung von
planungs und genehmigungsverfahren aber
nicht nur bei energien landen absenkung
des strompreises
2023 abschaffen der eeg-umlage es viel
zu spät verlängerung der sozial
garantien über
2021 hinaus
stärkung zb des eigenkapitals von
personenunternehmen oder sittens
flexibilisierung der arbeitszeit nicht
nur eine tageszeit wir wollen eine
wöchentliche höchstzeit und wir gehen
weiter ratifizierungen computer oder
auch anpassungen der korona helfen was
uns aber am meisten erschrocken hat ist
das staatsverständnis der ampel und am
meisten die größte enttäuschung ist die
fdp hier die fdp die sonst im wahlkampf
viel versprochen hat ordnungspolitisch
jetzt sehen wir der staat soll mehr
reguliert mehr intervenieren wettbewerb
beschneiden machen sie eines gleichen
sieht die kalte progression aus wie das
die cdu-geführten bundesregierung vor
ihnen gemacht haben ich sah am ende
lieber fdp es ist kein hexenwerk
wollen es wir machen eben weniger krass
und deshalb will ich ihn am schluss
sagen sehr geehrter herr haarberg sie
finden ein gut motiviertes und
aufgestelltes ministerium vor nutzen sie
es auch für die wirtschaftspolitik
julia klöckner war das seit dieser
legislaturperiode
stellvertretende vorsitzende in der
unionsfraktion eben in dem bereich
wirtschaft und
jetzt kommt wieder eine stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende auch noch nicht so
lange in diesem amt ist verena hubert
nämlich aus der spd fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrter
herr bundeswirtschaftsminister sie haben
richtigerweise über zeit gesprochen und
dass wir die brauchen und dass wir
endlich anpacken müssen es gibt manchmal
wichtigeres als dringlichkeit aber
häufig braucht es die dringlichkeit
damit wir die dinge auch schaffen und
das kennt wahrscheinlich jeder jede auch
so ein bisschen von sich selbst und wenn
wir ehrlich sind auch aus dem
politischen arbeiten wird immer
zielkonflikte geben was geht man jetzt
an wie geht man es an was es besonders
wichtig und dringlich aber eins liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das sage ich
ihnen die transformation die vor uns
liegt hinzu klimaneutralität zu einer
innovativen wirtschaft zu einer global
wettbewerbsfähigen wirtschaft das ist
dringlich das ist eben auch wichtig und
das werden wir gemeinsam mit einer
kraftanstrengung auch angehen
herbig hat diese woche eindrücklich
demonstriert erläutert wo wir stehen bei
unseren klimazielen hat auch von dem
berg gesprochen auf dem wir hoch müssen
und es wird auch anstrengend aber es
bleibt nichts anderes als dieses 1,5
grad ziel endlich anzugehen mit aller
dringlichkeit und wir müssen die
industrie umstellen das geht vom zement
zum stahl- chemie- und natürlich rüber
hinaus und das muss zu einer
klimaneutralen produktion kommen und das
werden wir auch schaffen
ja aber die transformation die bedeutet
doch auch viel mehr als gigawatt und co2
budgets da ist doch was im wandel wie
wandelt sich die arbeitswelt durch die
pandemie ja aber auch durch die
digitalisierung die automatisierung
künstliche intelligenz die art und weise
wie wir dinge produzieren da ist doch
einiges im wandel und ich bin dabei
erweckt das bietet doch chancen
natürlich mache ich mir auch gedanken
wenn arbeitsplätze in dieser krise wenn
wir da anders auch angehen müssen aber
es bietet natürlich auch die chance für
wachstum das da neues entstehen kann
schauen sie sich doch mal die
erneuerbaren energien das buch und die
solarindustrie hier gibt's startups in
berlin im bereich green technology die
bauen
photovoltaik-anlagen dezentral zur
vermietung für alle die sich auch gar
keine photovoltaik anlage leisten können
oder wollen dass wir hinkommen zu einer
anderen art des wirtschaftens
warum müssen wir handys nach zwei jahren
wegwerfen weil der akku nicht mehr geht
wir müssen doch hinkommen zu einer
wiederverwendung zu einer
kreislaufwirtschaft mit den materialien
auch behutsam umzugehen
und wenn man sich die deutsche
wirtschaft ansieht und anschaut dann
sehen wir wir haben das rüstzeug dazu
wir sind durch den mittelstand geprägt
und er hat uns erfolgreich gemacht
99 5 prozent aller unternehmen sind
klein oder mittel ständig und es ist das
flugzeug dass wir auch diese
transformation schaffen gemeinsam mit
den großkonzernen
da müssen wir auch mal ein klick auf den
dax werfen als gradmesser unserer
wirtschaft haben wir da mit sap
1972 gegründet den letzten
welterfolg digitaler natur aus
deutschland das reicht doch nicht wir
müssen das was wir haben das bewährte
wandeln aber es muss auch neues
entstehen und deswegen liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen brauchen wir auch ein
gründergeist in diesem land denn die dax
unternehmen der zukunft die wurden
vielleicht noch gar nicht gegründet und
sie haben über unternehmertum gesprochen
ich war selbst gründerinnen
unternehmerinnen und die
startvoraussetzungen die sind noch nicht
optimal wir müssen bürokratie abbauen
das darf nicht
ewige zettel geben von der gelben
gewerbeanmeldung bis zu sonstigen
formularen wir müssen da einfach
schneller werden bürokratie abbauen
mitarbeiter kapital stärken zugang zu
kapital stärken insbesondere in den
sogenannten späteren wachstumsphasen
auch durch den zukunftsfonds und auch
mehr frauen zum kunden bekommen
und ja in dieser transformation ist die
chance die ich eben angesprochen habe da
entstehen gerade ganz viele neue
industrien die halbleiterindustrie
wir haben die möglichkeit bei
wasserstoff vorne mit dabei zu sein e
mobilität und da ist ja auch die
nachfrage von den konsumentinnen und
konsumenten
und dieser wandel der wird doch durch
die menschen gemacht und das ist auch
kein generationenkonflikt kein alt gegen
jung das ist ein miteinander und diesen
wandel müssen wir auch alle miteinander
gemeinsam meistern
und wenn man sich mit unternehmen aus
tauscht dann gibt es ein thema leben der
bürokratie neben den energiepreisen aber
das betrifft alle und das ist der
fachkräftemangel
sie finden in der hotellerie in der
gesundheitswirtschaft in den tech
konzernen in den handwerksbetrieben
handwerklichen betrieben keine gute
nachwuchskräfte deswegen müssen wir auf
qualifizierung setzen wir müssen schauen
dass ist das weiterbilden dass wir das
wirklich als kernkompetenz verankern
aber auch dafür sorgen dass wir die
migration erleichtern und durch die
zuwanderung eben auch die fachkräfte
mangel situation beheben
ja und der staat und damit wir alle
gemeinsam spielen ja damit eine
erhebliche rolle wir wollen das nicht
von der seitenlinie betrachten wir
wollen anpacken wir wollen da die
rahmenbedingungen setzen wir wollen
ermöglichen und eben die probleme lösen
die unsere wirtschaft hat vom
fachkräftemangel von der planungs
beschleunigung von bürokratieabbau und
ein klick in den koalitionsvertrag zeigt
auch dass wir da sehr strategisch
vorgehen wir wollen transformations-
cluster bilden uns geografisch anschauen
wo sind wir denn gut in welcher region
wie können wir die leute zusammenbringen
die forschenden die unternehmen die
zivilgesellschaft auch über soziale
innovationen dinge lösen und hier
explizit
strukturschwache regionen unterstützen
denn wenn das wegfällt dann kann auch
etwas neues geschaffen werden
und ja die vergangenheit hat es gezeigt
in deutschland sind wir manchmal auch
ein bisschen gemütlich wir sind doch
manchmal pessimistisch bei der
industrialisierung vor rund 100 jahren
waren wir auch nicht vorne mit dabei
aber wenn wir mal anfangen dann legen
wir richtig los und ich freue mich
darauf und sehr geehrter herr
bundesminister liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die ampel koalition wird dieses
thema mit aller dringlichkeit angehen
und darauf können sie sich verlassen und
das packen wir an vielen dank
verena huber zwar dass stellvertretende
vorsitzende der spd-fraktion in der
debatte des bundestages über die
vorhaben des wirtschafts- und
klimaschutz ministeriums robert habeck
hatte eingangs einiges dazu referierte
wo seine zentralen anliegen sind alles
muss schneller werden sagte er flexibler
um klimaschutz ziele die sich die
bundesrepublik selbst gesetzt hat auch
tatsächlich erreichen zu können leif
erik holm für die afg fraktion da ist er
stellvertretender vorsitzender und ja
herr minister auch die fdp fraktion
wünsche ihnen natürlich ein glückliches
händchen für ihr wichtiges amt für unser
land vor allen dingen wünschen wir ihnen
augenmaß augenmaß ist sehr sehr wichtig
und ihr plan ihr klimaplan lässt den aus
unserer sicht deutlich vermissen er wird
dazu führen dass wir mit noch mehr
geschwindigkeit in die falsche richtung
fahren oder wird verdammt teuer der bund
der steuerzahler rechnen mit 50
milliarden oder auch mehr pro jahr damit
geht es dann noch schneller in die
energiepolitische sackgasse und das kann
sich deutschland bei weitem nicht
leisten
klar windkraftindustrie und
solarhersteller werden sich natürlich
freuen aber für die bürger und den rest
der wirtschaft wird es eben nochmal
teurer obwohl wir jetzt schon
rekordpreise haben bei strom gas heizung
sprit es reicht aber offensichtlich noch
nicht da soll jetzt noch der harbeck
bonus obendrauf und dabei treibt ist ja
schon jetzt wenn wir genau hinschauen
die unternehmen ins ausland oder sie
fahren ihre produktion herunter wie zum
beispiel die glashütte in freital dort
über steigen die energiekosten den
umsatz muss man sich mal vorstellen
der geschäftsführer sagt die politik
kann sich sämtliche corona hilfen sparen
wenn sie
die preisen keine lösung findet und
jetzt geht es noch mal in die falsche
richtung mit ihrem plan herberg werden
sie bald keinen wirtschaftsminister mehr
sein sondern insolvenz minister
sie wollen zwei prozent der bundesflagge
mit windrädern zu stellen wünsche ich
ihnen viel spaß dabei dass den ländern
schmackhaft zu machen bei mir in
mecklenburg vorpommern haben wir jetzt
schon an die drei hürden 3000 winter
lagen stehen und kaum noch einen freien
blick zum horizont und vor allem wird
das auch nichts nützen ja schau dir doch
mal bei uns vorbei in die nähe von
altentreptow oder auf rügen ging es wie
das dort aussieht das ist nicht der
richtige weg ganz einfach
es bleibt auch klar dass das nichts
nützen wird auch unter minister habeck
ist die wahrheit klar kein wind keine
sonne kein strom da können sie sich
gehackt legen es funktioniert nicht wir
brauchen grundlastfähigen strom in
unserem land
und dann müssen wir über eine
technologie reden über die unsere
nachbarn längst leben die reden auch
nicht nur die handeln schon wir müssen
über kernkraft sprechen es ist doch
kontraproduktiv und auch umweltfeindlich
laufende moderne kernkraftwerke vom netz
zu nehmen die günstig und sogar
emissionsfrei strom erzeugt
emissionsfrei und das ist doch ihr mann
tragen wenn sie also wirklich schnell
co2-emission abbauen wollen wenn sie
dazu eine sichere energieversorgung und
günstigen strom haben wollen dann
schaffen sie das nicht mit ihrem klima
hirngespinst sondern nur mit
kernkraftwerken legen sie also endlich
ihre ideologischen scheuklappen ab und
gehen sie den weg den andere längst
gehen das ist der weg der vernunft und
der plan macht die deutschen auch an die
explodierenden energiepreise sorgen
dafür dass viele weitere produkte jetzt
schon massiv verteuert werden wir spüren
es alle in den supermärkten die neue ezb
direktorin schnabel warnt bereits vor
einer verstetigung der inflation gerade
auch durch die klimapolitik und wenn
dazu dann noch die lohn preis spirale in
gang kommt dann wird es ungemütlich für
uns alle also kehren sie endlich um und
hören sie auf mit diesen koste es was es
wolle
andere aufgaben werden viel wichtiger
und davon habe ich noch nichts gehört
herr minister was ist mit der dringenden
notwendigen entlassung entlastung von
steuern und abgaben
wann gibt es endlich eine
entbürokratisierung die ihren namen
verdient war eine bessere infrastruktur
und wie schnell vor allen dingen ich
hätte gerne gehört was sie dagegen tun
wollen dass sie deutschlands anteil an
exportierten hightech-produkten seit
1990 halbiert hat während chinas anteil
von 1 auf 24 prozent gestiegen ist
unsere marktanteile schwimmt gerade in
dem bereich der in zukunft für unseren
wohlstand sorgen könnte und das kann
nicht sein
und ich hätte mir auch gewünscht dass
sie den mitarbeitern der werften die
gerade pleite gegangen sind in
mecklenburg vorpommern und in
bremerhaven heute etwas hoffnung geben
mit ideen aus ihrem haus wie wir die
werkstatt ort erhalten können da braucht
es eben auch einen intensiven einsatz
des bundes an dieser stelle das können
die länder nicht alleine schaffen dass
er habe haben die beschäftigten mit
sicherheit heute auch von ihnen erwartet
dazu ein wort zu hören
und wir brauchen dringend auch eine
perspektive für unsere corona
gebeutelten unternehmen im land gerade
die kleinen die kleinen einzelhändler
die touristiker die gastronomen die
kulturbetriebe aber statt eine
perspektive kommt jetzt auch noch zweig
plus dabei ist doch jetzt mittlerweile
klar es gibt doch die studien die das
zeigen dass mit omikron die belastung
der endsieg strafft intensivstationen um
drei viertel zurückgeht die zahl der
todesfälle sogar 90 prozent
da müssen sie jetzt ran herr minister
sorgen sie dafür dass unsere unternehmen
endlich wieder arbeiten dürfen ist es
zeit für eine öffnung
herr minister es gibt genug zu tun aber
sie müssen eben auch das richtige tun
ihr klimaplan ist ein kompletter er
wirkt die mittel sind falsch die kosten
zu hoch und die folgen für die bürger
werden leider dramatisch seien deswegen
sage ich noch einmal wir brauchen
politik mit augenmaß
vielen dank
und das verlangt live ihre kolben
stellvertretender vorsitzender der fdp
fraktion vom neuen bundeswirtschafts-
und klimaschutzminister robert habeck
nächster redner in dieser debatte in der
es oben das ressort von robert habe geht
es lukas köhler stellvertretender
vorsitzender der fdp-fraktion und umwelt
und klimaschutz politiker
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen lieber minister
das internet ist nur ein hype der satz
ist nicht von mir sondern von bill gates
1993 hat er sich nicht vorstellen können
dass neue technologien zu etwas neuem
oder was guten für wenn ich mir die
reden der union und der afg hier so
anhöre dann sind sie ein bisschen wie
bill gates 1993
keine ahnung davon wie und was
eigentlich innovation und fortschritt
ist aber und das ist ja eine hoffnung
die wir haben können will gates hat dazu
gelernt wenn ich mir microsoft heute
angucke haben die gelernt und bei der
union habe ich da wirklich hoffnung da
hab ich wirklich hoffnung dass auch die
union wirtschaftspolitik von heute
lernen bei der afg
ist die hoffnung ein bisschen
der weg zum 15 grad ziel ist ein weg den
wir nur mit fortschritt und neuen
technologien bestreiten können damit ist
er aber ein weg der prosperität ist ein
weg der dazu führt dass wir
preisstabilität
klimaneutralität und die
innovationskraft miteinander verbinden
und das ist wirtschaftswachstum meine
damen er das ist die kern definition
davon wie wir unsere wirtschaft aufbauen
und nach vorne will
und ja diese frau klöckner wir brauchen
einen turbo wir brauchen eine menge
turbos aber turbo liebe frau klöckner
ist kein charakter aus dem
zeichentrickfilm
turbo ist das was wir brauchen wenn wir
innovationskraft entfesselt durch
planungs beschleunigung durch
bürokratieabbau durch all die dinge die
minister habe hier angesprochen da hilft
es wenn man der rede dann auch die
nötige würdigung denn das hat er genau
an dieser stelle gerade den weg nach
vorne der weg davon ist der einzige
diese beschreiben können und das geht
nur wenn wir natürlich darauf achten
dass wir die inflation in den griff die
inflation wird aber im moment getrieben
durch hohe energiepreise hohe
energiepreise setzen sich aus
rohstoffpreisen und bürokratie und
abgaben müssen zusammen und die können
wir sinken die rohstoffpreise sänken wir
dadurch dass wir massiv in erneuerbare
energien investiert
sie sagten wir aber auch dadurch dass
wir ein konzept von morgen entwickeln
indem wir ein neues strommarkt design
auf den weg bringen werden die senken
dadurch dass wir für bezugsquellen
international für energie für co2
neutrale moleküle so die abgaben und
steuern die müssen wir senken die müssen
wir dadurch senken dass wir jetzt in
dieser reform schnell vorankommen aber
meine damen und herren das ist ja keine
leichte aufgabe das ganze ist ein
gewachsenes system und dieses gewachsene
system das werden wir nur in den griff
bekommen wenn wir drei punkte
miteinander verbinden in der idee einer
funktionierenden energie und das sind
zum einen die auf der aspekt der
versorgungssicherheit
wir dürfen in deutschland keine stunde
kam zu keiner zeit im jahr der strom
ausgehen ist weil das ist etwas das wir
uns nicht leisten können nicht nur
volkswirtschaftlich sondern auch in der
akzeptanz der bevölkerung wir müssen es
aber gleichzeitig verbinden mit dem weg
zur klimaneutralität den wir jetzt in
diesen kommenden jahren anfangs wir
müssen uns auf den weg machen der wird
beendet sein spätestens 20 45 aber auf
den weg müssen uns machen wir müssen es
aber gleichzeitig mit günstigen preisen
bekommen und wenn wir die steuern und
ablagen reformieren dann
sorgen wir dafür dass der co2 preis die
tragende rolle spielt der
emissionshandel sorgt dafür dass ganz
klar wird und ist wie unser weg aussehen
wird aber
wir müssen dann eine alternative bieten
eine alternative für diejenigen die
strom günstig brauchen das sind die
erneuerbaren energien die laufen aber
nicht den ganzen tag und dazu braucht
das gaskraftwerk wir werden in
gaskraftwerke investieren müssen als
übergang werden wir da erdgas verbrennen
das ist ganz klar das ist auch kein
problem weil wir das günstig sinnvoll
und schnell hinkriegen wird aber als
über das heißt dass auch der das gas
enden und dann wird es mit wasser und
wasserstoff da können wir heute genau
diese weichen stellen über die
innovation über die wir gerade
gesprochen haben über die wir gerade die
wichtigen ideen vernommen haben die wir
umsetzen wollen diese innovationen sind
ja schon längst auf dem weg ist es ja
nicht so dass das alles noch nicht kommt
sondern es gibt die ideen die
technologien die wege der ingenieurinnen
und ingenieure in deutschland die jetzt
schon beschritten werden dazu brauchen
wir aber eine technologieoffene eine
technologie
neutrale formulierung dessen was wir uns
vorstellen und dazu muss die techniken
die wasserstoff regulatorisch in
deutschland technologieoffen aufgestellt
werden wir das hinbekommen wenn wir
dieses race zusicherungen gegen china
und die usa gewinnen wollen dann müssen
wir gemeinsam an einem strang ziehen und
dann müssen wir wirtschaftspolitik von
morgen machen ich glaube auf dem
richtigen weg sind wir schon als ampel
regierung und freund
lukas kohler für die koalitionsfraktion
wenn man so will und jetzt kommt klaus
ernst
dieser legislaturperiode vorsitzender im
ausschuss für klimaschutz und energie
eine nicht ganz unumstritten
entscheidung auch in der linksfraktion
sehr verehrten damen und herren er habe
ich erst mal recht herzlichen
glückwunsch zu ihrem neuen amt es ist
eine sehr schwierige aufgabe
ich wünsche ihnen den besten erfolg vor
allen dingen natürlich bei den projekten
wo unsere meinung übereinstimmen kann
sie aber warnen ist es sieht nicht sehr
viele wo wir unterschiedliche positionen
positionen haben aber einige schonen und
die werde ich natürlich auch ansprechen
wir sind mit ihnen der auffassung dass
wir das 1,5 grad ziel erreichen müssen
wir sind für einen raschen ausstieg aus
der kohle atomenergie
tut mir leid das ist ein unumkehrbarer
weg aus dieser atomenergie auszusteigen
gott sei dank werden wir gehen und ich
habe ja bei jeder dabei ihre regeln sie
haben die serben des abrieb verstellt
horizont verstellt wegen windräder ich
habe den eindruck bei ihnen ist der
horizont aus ideologischen gründen
verstellt und deshalb würde ich würde
ich ein bisschen vor sich meine damen
und herren
wir haben den fakt klöckner dass die
letzte bundesregierung tatsächlich
verschlafen hat die der neuen bahn
energien auszubauen und deshalb in dem
zusammenhang von grüne planwirtschaft zu
sprechen fragt man sich ja hier ein
altmaier zurück
er war er war ja an dieser er war an
dieser frage einfach deutlich weiter der
hat von industrie politik gesprochen da
habe ich von ihnen eh nix gehört es tut
mir leid das war nicht sehr erfolgreich
was ich hier dargestellt aber er habe
die aufgabe die sie haben dieses jahr
schwierige aufgabe können wir nur
hinkriegen wenn man die bürger dazu
gewinnen ein punkt wo wir sie gewinnen
ist dass man beim ausbau der windkraft
nicht nur die beteiligung der bürger im
anfangsstadium der planung brauchen
sondern wir brauchen die beteiligung der
bürger auch dann wenn es ums geld geht
und ich sage ihnen eines eigenen
erfahrungen bei eigenen wahlkreis
die die ein windrad vor ihrer haustür
akzeptieren müssen ausreichend noch
immer wenn die beteiligt werden auch an
dem auch das windrad bringt dann steigt
auch die bereitschaft des zu akzeptieren
deshalb bitte ich sie in diesem weg hier
vor anker und zweitens wir haben dass
ich hier richtig eine explosion der
energiepreise
der großhandelspreis für erdgas an der
börse ist allein in den vergangenen
zwölf monaten um 250 prozent gestiegen
exorbitant für jana und fieber haben wir
laut dem vergleichsportal verivox bisher
515 der rund 700 gasversorger erhöhungen
von durchschnittlich 23 prozent
angekündigt preis für benzin bin ich
gerne darüber reden aber hier habe ich
das hat nichts mit ihrer politik zu tun
klar so lange sind sie ja noch nicht im
amt aber diese entwicklung schürt die
angst der bürger auch vor einer
energiewende weil das ja mit energie zu
tun und deshalb müssen wir doch jetzt
sofort dringend eingreifen und ich sage
ihnen der verweis auf den mindestlohn
der wird ja erhöht dann ist alles nicht
so schlimm die erreicht nicht die
wollten den mindestlohn schon erhöhen da
gab der blogger energiepreis explosion
deshalb brauchen sie zusätzliche
maßnahmen dass jetzt die bürger an
dieser frage entlastet und zwar sofort
wir schlagen vor dass wir kurzfristig
über die absenkung der mehrwertsteuer
bei strom heizöl erdgas betrieben und
kurzfristige entlastung hinzukriegen das
wäre eine möglichkeit hier was zu tun
im industriellen bereich
brauchen wir natürlich geld also zehn
milliarden für die stahlindustrie dass
du zuerst auf gas und dann auf
wasserstoff umstellen können dass es
jetzt gefordert ich habe den eindruck
das hauptproblem ihrer energiepolitik
ist die finanzierung und das was sie
vorgeschlagen haben nachdem sie
schuldenbremse aussetzen und ähnliches
ja nicht wollen wir in klimafonds sie
wissen dass selbst er steht auf tönernen
rechtlichen füßen und wir müssen
dringend hinkriegen dass er bei der
finanzierung nicht die kleinen leute
belasten sondern auch die belasten die
in der letzten zeit hervorragend
verdient haben die vermögen sind
gestiegen die gewinne sind gestiegen wir
brauchen dort eine veränderte
steuerpolitik haben sie auch geld für
die industrie finden
und ein weiterer mann den ich sehr an
ihrer politik haben ja die
eröffnungsbilanz klimaschutz vorgestellt
habe ich das wort arbeitsplätze kommt
diese bilanz nicht einmal vor
im übrigen auch die sicherung von
beschäftigung nur am rande erwähnt
wir müssen bei der freude klima politik
auch überlegen welche technischen
lösungen wir forcieren die im blick auf
ihre wirkung auch eine möglichst hohe
zahl von arbeitsplätzen ermöglichen das
ist keine automatik was wir sagen ja wir
machen klimaschutz und dann gibt es neue
jobs das wird in vielen bereichen zu
sein aber es würde gleichzeitig zu sein
dass momentan viele leute das sehen wir
ja angst um ihre jobs haben deshalb
müssen ja auch bei den technischen
lösungen die wir anbieten und die
brauchen da haben sie vollkommen recht
da müssen wir auch darüber reden wie
können wir die technische lösungen
vorantreiben insbesondere arbeitsplätze
erhalten und
zum schluss
[Musik]
ich freue mich natürlich dass auch sie
jetzt erkannt haben ich hoffe dass setzt
sich in den regalen fraktion durch das
war gas als zwischen technologie
brauchen es war ja nicht immer so heiße
schlachten würden geschlagen und wendig
sowie es dass sich diese erkenntnis bei
ihnen durchsetzt dann würde mich freuen
wenn sie das auch frau berbalk mal
sorgen herzlichen dank dank ihnen
klaus ernst war das für die
linksfraktion und außerdem ist er
vorsitzender im ausschuss für
klimaschutz und energie und sprecherin
für klimaschutz und energie in der
fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen ist
ingrid nestle und die ist die nächste
rednerin hier in dieser debatte genau zu
diesem thema
[Applaus]
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ich habe großen respekt vor der aufgabe
die unsere koalition sich vorgenommen
hat nämlich die energieversorgung sicher
und sauber zu gestalten ich habe großen
respekt davor wenn keiner schüttelt eine
energiewende einfach aus dem ärmel und
zudem sind wir in ganz vielen bereichen
schwer im rückstand der ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien ist ein sehr
deutliches beispiel dafür und deshalb
und deshalb ist es genau richtig was
minister habe ich gestern gemacht hat
nämlich innerhalb kürzester zeit wenn
wir ehrlich sind aber nicht viel mehr
als eine weihnachtspause zwischen
amtsantritt und gestern in kürzester
zeit ein umfangreiches paket vorzulegen
für die energiewende das den ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien massiv
beschleunigen wird
das ist genau richtig aus verschiedenen
gründen und herr ernst vielleicht hat ja
hab ich das wort arbeitsplatz verwendet
ich habe aber genau gehört wie er von
der wirtschaftspolitik für gesellschaft
und arbeit gesprochen hat und ich glaube
wir sollten uns nicht über worte sondern
über inhalte unterhalten und ja
natürlich sind erneuerbaren energien
auch ein arbeitsplatz münster
es ist auch genau richtig die
erneuerbaren energien jetzt auszubauen
weil sie für alle drei zentralen fragen
der energieversorgung die antwort sind
wir wollen energieversorgung sauber wir
wollen sie sicher und wir wollen sie
bezahlbar haben sauber ist im moment
nicht das kann keiner behaupten und die
erneuerbaren energien sind der schlüssel
um die sauber zu bekommen sicher ist die
energieversorgung zurzeit aber damit sie
sicher bleibt muss natürlich der zu oft
funktionieren
es kann ja nicht reichen aus atom und
kohle auszusteigen wenn man nicht
gleichzeitig den zubau auch tatsächlich
hinbekommt und dafür hat er habe gestern
die maßnahmen folgen
die energieversorgung muss aber auch
bezahlbar sein und derzeit ist sie für
viele nicht mehr bezahlbar weil die
energiepreise explodieren weil weil die
gaspreise die preise für fossiles gas
explodiert sind und in der folge auch
die strompreise und herr räumen da haben
sie die wirklichkeit wirklich vollkommen
verdreht ja energie ist teuer aber nein
energie ist nicht teuer wegen der
nachbarn energien und der ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien ist der schlüssel
dafür mittelfristig die energie partie
darunter zu gucken ist der schlüssel
dafür ist der westen abhängig machen von
den gleich steigerung ist völlig
unberechenbar preis explosionen die die
fossilen uns gerade bescheren und dann
kommen die wahrscheinlich widerstand
jetzt hab ich gesagt aber ich werd scho
das nicht denken ja aber wind und die
sonne ist doch wetterabhängig ja
natürlich sind die wetter abhängig aber
jedes megawatt mehr wind oder pv könnte
die preise ein stück weit senken hätten
wir mehr erneuerbare bei strom und wärme
dann wären die gasspeicher deutlich
besser gefüllt und wir würden uns heute
keine sorgen über einen preis explosion
machen
atom sie genannt atome sowieso dreimal
so teuer als erneuerbare also eine reine
ich möchte der vergangenheit leben aber
nichts in der realität zu tun haben da
aussage jetzt muss ich leider zum
schluss kommen ich wünsche mir sehr und
ich bin überzeugt dass wir es
hinbekommen eine nicht ideologisch
geprägte debatte zu führen sondern eine
die dafür sorgen dass die
stromversorgung die energieversorgung
wirklich funktionieren sicher
bezahlbaren einklang mit den klimazielen
selbst damit werden wir alle hände voll
zu tun haben und ich freue mich sehr auf
die aufgabe es geht los
ingrid nestle freut sich auf die aufgabe
die eine große sein wird was nicht nur
kritikerinnen das vorhaben von robert
habeck angeht auch
wohlwollende betrachter das vorhaben zu
sehen da eine eine großen berg der
abzuarbeiten sein wird andreas jung ist
der nächste redner sprecher für
klimaschutz und energie der
unionsfraktion
kolleginnen und kollegen der klimaschutz
ist eine herausragende globale aufgabe
des pariser abkommen ist der gemeinsame
rahmen für die antwort der
internationalen gemeinschaft und es geht
darum dass wir in deutschland unseren
konsequenten beitrag dazu leisten das
ist unsere gemeinsame grundlagen und auf
dieser grundlage herr minister will ich
gerne das aufnehmen was sie
vorgeschlagen haben nämlich ein
wettbewerb um das beste modell um dieses
ziel zu erreichen wir werden dafür
vorangehen wir haben dafür vorschläge
gemacht und ich will ihnen sagen was
unsere haltung dabei ist unsere haltung
ist das von vornherein konsequenter
klimaschutz immer zusammengedacht werden
muss was untrennbar ist mit
wirtschaftlicher stärke mit sozialem
ausgleich das ist nachhaltigkeit in der
ganzen breite das ist unteilbar und das
ist der weg der zum erfolg führt bei nur
der mit dauerhafte akzeptanz verbunden
dass sie für das werk klimaziele
erreichen arbeitsplätze erhalten die
menschen mitnehmen
und dazu gehört auch dass wir akzeptanz
erhalten und deshalb ist entscheidend
dass wir diesen weg so gehen dass wir
den menschen sagen selbstverständlich
werden wir die klimaziele erreicht aber
auf diesem weg wird mobilität bezahlbar
bleiben wird energie bezahlbar bleiben
wird wohnen bezahlbar bleiben in der
stadt und auf dem land und dazu werden
wir die richtigen regeln auf den weg
bringen
sie haben beschrieben es gibt einen
konsens einen breiten konsens über das
klimaziel deutschland muss bis 2045
klimaneutral werden das haben wir der
bundesgrenze in der großen koalition im
sommer gemeinsam beschlossen als wir
beschlossen haben haben die einen gesagt
herr lindner die fdp das ist zu schnell
2050 ist ausreichend und die anderen
habe die grüne sagte es ist zu spät wir
müssen schneller schaffen und sie haben
es in unterschiedlicher tonlage die ein-
und sachlich die anderen polemisch
kritisiert ist dass uns alles sehr viel
schneller gehen deshalb ja ist ein
wichtiger schritt dass die ampel jetzt
gesagt hat dass wir beschlossen am
klimaneutralität 2045 das ist unser
beitrag zum pariser abkommen und seines
beschlossen haben in all ihren reden sie
heute gesagt sagen sie das ist ein
ehrgeiziges ziel und ja das ist es und
weil es ein ehrgeiziges ziel ist sein
bisher mit einem instrumentarium
unterlegt im klimaschutzgesetz und ich
frage sie herr bundeskanzler herr
minister was ist eigentlich ein
klimaschutzgesetz geworden als wir
beschlossen haben gerade die spd auch in
den debatten unsere gemeinsame haltung
dargestellt das ist der weg damit wir
klimaziele einhalten da wird in
jahresscheiben und den sektoren
runtergebrochen was muss gemacht werden
es wird sofort über prüfen sie nicht
erreicht wird nach gesteuert und von
ihrer partei ist in besonderer weise die
haltung gekommen da braucht man
eigentlich nur den politischen willen
und das offensichtliche sofort möglich
zu beschließen und dann geht es seit sie
regieren das im koalitionsvertrag
festgehalten das klimaschutzgesetz sind
aufgeweicht werden in ihren überlegungen
hat gar keine rolle gespielt ich frage
sie was ist mit dem klimaschutzgesetz
diese position müssen sie klären
sie haben uns an ihrer seite bei einem
beschleunigten ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien sagte dazu sie müssen noch
besser erklären wie sie auf ihre
zielmarke von 80 prozent kommen der
verweist auf den koalitionsvertrag als
quelle reicht da nicht die zahlreichen
studien dies ergibt legen nahe dass eine
erhöhung richtig ist aber die zielmarke
von 80 prozent erklärt sich daraus noch
nicht das müssen sie besser erklären bei
dem weg den sie beschrieben haben sind
wir dabei wenn es im planungs
beschleunigen das im deutschen bundestag
beschlossen ein
planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz grüne und
fdp hatten dagegen gestimmt ist es gut
wenn wir es jetzt gemeinsam machen es
ist wichtig dass das mit den ländern
bespricht und diesen hinweis wünschen
auch geben bei der frage wie kommen wir
da ran da kommt es ja aus detail einen
kanister dafür sind eben noch keine
massnahmen vorgeschlagen worden das sind
ziele vorgestellt worden aber noch keine
maßnahmen die umweltministerkonferenz
die umweltkonferenz ringt seit jahren
über die frage wie die belange des
artenschutzes und der erneuerbaren
energien zusammen gebracht werden können
siering seit jahren darum aber sie haben
noch kein ergebnis in der habeck das
sind 11 grüne minister dabei eine
ministerin findet cdu und ich kann ihnen
sagen ich habe mit ihr gesprochen ein
delikt nicht was eine schwierige frage
ist auf die brauchen wir eine antwort
ist eine gesellschaftliche
herausforderung
die auf beispielhafte das steht was wir
brauchen ja wir haben überragend
desinteresse der erneuerbaren
voranzubringen
es geht oft mit akzeptanz und für die
akzeptanz brauchen wir den ausgleich mit
dem artenschutz mit dem naturschutz mit
den anwohnern und das muss alles
zusammengebracht werden und es geht
nicht durch eine verordnung durch ein
gesetz in berlin so es geht nur durch
überzeugung durch dialog mit den ländern
mit den kommunalen spitzenverbänden mit
den menschen vor ort und das ist unser
weg und
was denn die frage des gases angeht der
teile ich das was der kollege lukas
köhler gesagt hat ich frage nur sie ist
es die haltung von lukas köhler die sich
auch so im koalitionsvertrag der ampel
wiederfindet oder eher wichtig sie
weisen darauf hin steht im
koalitionsvertrag aber ist es auch die
position der ganzen bundesregierung her
habe als die eu ihre taxonomie
vorgestellt hat die er beinhaltet das in
wasserstoff fähige gaskraftwerke von
privaten investiert wird dass es begrüßt
werden soll dann sie gesagt das ist
fraglich sie haben im koalitionsvertrag
das bekenntnis zu investitionen in gas
sie haben dort keine antwort geben soll
und wenn dann private investieren sollen
halten sie es für fraglich wollen sie
ist den selber machen ich vermute auch
nicht dann brauchen wir aber die
investitionen von privaten dafür
brauchen mit einem richtigen rahmen und
das ist die notwendige antwort für den
übergang zu einer auf erneuerbaren
energien in vollem umfang gestützten
energieversorgung die
versorgungssicherheit klimaschutz und
die frage der preise zusammenbringt
nachhaltigkeit in der ganzen breite und
letzte bemerkung dazu gehört auch die
finanzielle nachhaltigkeit
auch das ist ein maßstab indem wir ihre
regierung gemessen werden die schulden
können sie es nachhaltigkeit in
verfassungsrechtlich wir müssen beides
zusammenbringen verantwortung bei umwelt
und klima für die kommenden generation
wir dürfen auch nicht die kommenden
generationen übermäßig mit schulden
belasten darum werden wie ihre politik
messen das ist unser weg herzlichen dank
und reaktion aus der unions fraktion
sucht nach widersprüchen in der
ampelkoalition und vermutet sie in der
frage zum thema gas als
übergangstechnologie für die strom- und
energiegewinnung nächster redner in
dieser debatte zu den vorhaben des
ministeriums für wirtschaft und
klimaschutzes matthias miersch
stellvertretender vorsitzender der
spd-fraktion
kolleginnen und kollegen auch von mir
herr minister habe keinen herzlichen
glückwunsch
ich habe mich gefragt was ich ihnen
sozusagen in meiner ersten rede wo
sieben minister sind schenken kann und
ich habe mich in den letzten
tagen ein bisschen oder hatte den
eindruck dass sie doch die last dieses
minister amtes ganz schön spüren und
deswegen will ich ihnen schenken ein
zitat eines
großen sozialdemokraten nämlich kurz
schumacher der 1946 gesagt hat man muss
begeistert sein um große taten zu
vollbringen
das sagt jemand der geschundenen aus der
kriegszeit kommt ich will nicht sagen
dass diese zeiten vergleichbar sind aber
die begeisterung für die aufgaben die
vor ihnen vor uns liegen die brauchen
wir und die müssen wir immer wieder
zeigen dass das und das hat verena
robert fand ich so toll gesagt das ja in
dieser großen transformation enorme
chancen sind das in neuen technologien
die chancen für arbeitsplätze sind das
nur die länder erfolgreich sein können
mit einer exportwirtschaft die in
innovation mit investieren und das ist
der sozialdemokratische weg den wir in
dieser koalition mit hineinbringen
wollen
und es ist schon ein bisschen putzig
andreas junglas jetzt nun ausgerechnet
die cdu der erfinder des
klimaschutzgesetzes ist meine für eine
der großen errungenschaften dass dieses
klimaschutzgesetz von sozialdemokraten
durchgesetzt und robert habeck dieses
instrument jetzt nutzen kann um effektiv
für die bundesregierung klimaschutz hier
tatsächlich zu realisieren
und auch herr minister ein punkt haben
wir ihnen schon mal weg geräumt wir
haben einen konsens in diesem land über
den kohleausstieg auch das ist eine
gesellschaftspolitische historische
leistung die aber natürlich niemals
ausreicht und sie haben recht und alle
anderen die das hier kritisiert haben
haben auch recht wir sind in der großen
koalition ein einigen punkten weiter
gekommen aber an dem schlüssel nicht
ausreichend und der schlüssel für die
zukunft ist der maximale ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien das ist der punkt
der jetzt vor uns
ja wir haben den solar deckel
abgeschafft wir haben auch kollege ernst
möglichkeiten der beteiligung des
schaffen für kommunen und für
bürgerinnen und bürger bei an
windkraftanlagen aber wir müssen da noch
drauflegen
und da geht es jetzt tatsächlich um ganz
ganz viel und da bin ich bei den großen
taten
wir werden hier jetzt konkret sein
müssen über klimaziele reden wir locker
über ausbauziele werden wir locker das
haben wir nicht mal geschafft herr
kollege brinkhaus da waren wir schon
auseinander weil sie da blockiert das
haben wir jetzt im koalitionsvertrag
aber jetzt geht es um die konkrete
umsetzung
und da haben sie
eben beziehungsweise auch die letzten
tage schon gesagt sie halten was gegen
kommissionen ich weiß wir lagen da auch
mit kohle kommissionen ganz auf einer
linie ich sage ihnen aber sie haben sich
über das große ministerbüro bewundert
und sagen da könnten sie den ein oder
anderen verwandten einladen mein
ratschlag ist
dass wir die unterschiedlichen
stakeholder die wir haben die
naturschutzverbände die energie verbände
an einen tisch holen das muss keine
kommission seien aber nur mal kurz ein
bilaterales minister gespräch wird nicht
reichen wir haben massive konflikte die
wir lösen müssen zwischen art zwischen
erneuerbaren energien wenn man das macht
und das ist meine erfahrung im wahlkreis
sind alle dazu bereit aber es muss auf
augenhöhe passieren und deswegen meine
bitte habe überlegen sie noch mal den
weg wie sie tatsächlich dass in den
nächsten monaten auflösen wollen wir
müssen da alle miteinander mitnehmen und
kennt
und sie haben zwei länder genannt
exemplarisch für den wind ausbau
2% für den wir streiten was ist das
gesetzgeberische ziel das heißt noch
nicht die realisierung und deswegen auch
hier meine bitte es ist gut wenn sie die
ministerpräsidenten besuchen wir haben
im eeg ein koordinierungs mechanismus
zwischen bund und ländern und wir haben
im koalitionsvertrag verankert dass wir
den ausbauen wollen ich glaube wir
brauchen ein wettbewerb zwischen und mit
den ländern dass die länder gefördert
werden die tatsächlich richtig nach
vorne wollen und deswegen herr minister
weg nutzen sie diesen koordinierungs
mechanismus laden sie die länder ein um
hier gemeinsam weiter zu kommen wir
werden die realisierung der erneuerbaren
nur schaffen wenn bund ländern und
kommunen an einem strang ziehen das
glaube ich es erschließen
und nun noch ein letzter punkt weil
atomkraft hier immer wieder genannt
wurden ja wir sind das land was aus
kohle und atom aussteigt gleichzeitig
und ich wünsche mir dass die
klimabewegung an vielen stellen auch das
thema atomkraft problematisiert denn wer
atomkraft als lösung bezeichnet eine
technologie die müll 30.000 generationen
nach uns weiter über lässt ohne dass wir
eine lösung dafür haben der macht den
menschen was vor das ist keine
zukunftsfähige lösung liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
und die taxonomie die taxonomie und das
sage ich ihnen herrn bundeskanzler und
ihnen herr habeck ist nur ein teil wir
müssen auf europäischer ebene die frage
stellen welchen energiemix die
europäische kommission denn für die
jahre 2050 ford folgende vorsieht wenn
der übergang atom und gas es habe ich
dafür volles verständnis weil die
mitgliedsstaaten ganz unterschiedlich
staaten in diese transformation aber es
darf nicht sein dass atom einen festen
platz hat in der zukünftigen
energieversorgung dafür ist sie nicht
nachhaltig dafür ist sie zu teuer und
deswegen müssen wir gemeinsam dafür
kämpfen dass auf nationaler ebene auf
europäischer ebene und herr
bundeskanzler zu recht im rahmen des
klima klubs alles für die erneuerbaren
getan wird das ist der schlüssel für die
zukunft das ist der schlüssel auch für
den erfolg der deutschen wirtschaft
vielen dank
nächster redner für die fdp fraktion
carsten hilse ich will aber vorher
erhielt sie wenn sie mir gestatten eine
kurze bemerkung machen sie haben gerade
ein paar kreative
umbaumaßnahmen vorgenommen das ist
selbstverständlich nicht ihre aufgabe
deswegen sage ich ihnen zu dass wir
sicherstellen werden dass sie alle die
von oben reden müssen aufgrund der
derzeitigen situation eine möglichkeit
bekommen auch ihr redemanuskript ablegen
zu können so dass sie das nicht selber
machen müssen und jetzt jetzt jetzt
erteile ich ihnen das wort für ihre rede
herzlichen dank
[Musik]
das ist aber gut frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren liebe landsleute
gestatten sie auch mir eine kurze
vorbemerkung während sich andere
europäische länder der einschätzung der
whu aus dem vorigen jahr anschließen und
cupid in zukunft als eine mittelschwere
grippe behandeln heben sie die
grundgesetzlich garantierten
freiheitsrechte aus belegen
medizinisches personal praktisch mit
berufsverbot machen bürger und frei
gewählte abgeordnete zu menschen zweiter
klasse wenn sie sich der experimentellen
therapie entziehen das erinnere an die
dunkelsten zeiten der geschichte herr
minister haarweg nimmt man ihre
regierungserklärung so ernst wie die
vermutlich gemeint ist dann haben sie
damit dem deutschen volk den schnellsten
weg in den untergang gezeigt und ich bin
sicher auch wenn sie nicht wissen wovon
sie reden sie meinen es ernst
sie wollen die geschwindigkeit mit der
das rotgrüne narrenschiff in richtung
abgrund reiße noch einmal erhöhen
nachdem mittels eeg die menschen seit
über 20 jahren gnadenlos ausgeplündert
werden bis jetzt rund eine billion euro
wollen sie die ausplünderung noch
forcieren der klimaschutz verlange es so
behaupten sie wohl wissend dass der
deutsche sonderweg von dem niemanden und
niemanden auf der welt auch nur
ansatzweise mit gegangen wird sollte die
hypothese dass die menschen gemachten
co2 emissionen das klima maßgeblich
beeinflussen stimmen was übrigens
tausend wissenschaftler weltweit
bestreiten würden sie die hypothetische
erderwärmung um wenige tausendstel grad
verringern die verantwortlichen in china
indien und allen anderen
entwicklungsländern kommen vor lachen
nicht in den schlaf der dümmsten
energiepolitik und der selbstzerstörung
der deutschen wirtschaft aber mit der
zerstörung der eigenen wirtschaft geben
sie sich nicht zufrieden auch die
naturzerstörung muss forciert werden
daher wollen sie das bisherige tempo des
um flügels der deutschen
kulturlandschaft verdreifachen auf zwei
prozent der landesfläche sollen daher
jede menge wind industrie anlagen gebaut
werden das sei im nationalen interesse
behaupten sie und ihre koalitionspartner
auch die vertreter der freiheit in der
mitte des parlaments
diese zwei prozent sind natürlich ein
zum himmel stinkende betrug da hier nur
die unmittelbar bebaute fläche berechnet
wird doch jeder dieser vogel schredder
braucht abstand zum nächsten
kugelschreiber je größer ist desto
größer die einst beanspruchte fläche und
damit wären es zwei prozent schnell neun
bis zehn prozent das sind dann rund
36.000 quadratkilometer mehr als die
gesamte bebaute fläche in unserem
vaterland das sind nämlich nur acht
prozent also alle städte und dörfer
zusammengenommen und strom bei flaute
liefern diese krank machen den ungetümen
natürlich auch nicht allein das würde
schon ausreichen sie und ihre berater
auf ihren geisteszustand untersuchen zu
lassen sie lassen zudem völlig außer
acht dass die deutschen schon heute im
wesentlichen befeuert durch ihren grünen
klima rettungswesen und völlig konträr
zu grünen versprechungen wir alle kennen
die lüge von der kugel eine kugel eis im
monat unter den höchsten strom öl und
gaspreisen der welt und nicht nur das am
wochenmarkt im wochentakt vermelden die
medien stromausfälle über das ganze land
verteilt hamburg dresden berlin
regensburg und und und und schon jetzt
ist der strom des extrem instabil mehr
als 8000 eingriffe ins netz hunderte
stromabschaltungen waren im letzten jahr
notwendig damit das stromnetz nicht
kollabiert und das ganze land im dunkeln
sitzen waren es anfangs dieses
jahrhunderts noch zehn eingriffe pro
jahr sind es jetzt knapp 40 pro tag
gemein brünen wähler macht das alles
nichts aus er tankt weiterhin seine
sowie falls zahlt gerne 40 oder 60 cent
pro kilowatt an und geht mit dem ruhigen
gewissen sagt ins bett weil er glaubt
die welt retten zu helfen otto
normalverbraucher und seine familie
können das nicht sie werden zwar
gezwungen bei der welten rettung zu
helfen sie müssen aber zusätzlich
entscheiden ob sie ihr geld mehr für
mehr für das heizen ausgeben oder fürs
essen heizen oder essen aber immer im
bewusstsein die welt zu retten wird sich
spaßig an ist es aber nicht irgendwer
noch bei klarem verstand ist muss bei
ihren plänen der spaß vergehen es ist
bitterer ernst sieben minister weg
wollen den untergang deutschlands
schließlich fanden sie vaterlandsliebe
schon immer zum kotzen wir nicht hier
lieben unser vaterland und werden uns
jedem angriff contra zu leben
entschlossen entgegenstellen
auch darin unterscheiden wir uns von den
grünen kommunisten und albig ihnen
wieder mit marschieren aber irgendwann
werden sie alle sich verantworten müssen
für die verarmung und wie die
verelendung großer teile des deutschen
volkes für die zehntausenden toten bei
einem blackout und durch die gentherapie
schäden für die ebenen des weges in den
totalitarismus und vor allem für die
geschundenen kinderseelen aufgrund ihrer
menschenverachtenden corona politik
nicht feine weltlichen gericht
vielleicht aber schwitzen kann wenn die
vorherige verstehen ich verachte sie bis
auf wenige ausnahmen zutiefst
[Applaus]
torsten hülse aus der spd-fraktion das
wird darf eine
information die ich ihnen nicht
vorenthalten möchte zum thema strom
jetzt den das deutsche stromnetz ist
tatsächlich stabiler als manche sagen in
den vergangenen jahren gab es sogar
deutlich weniger stromausfälle die
durchschnittliche unterbrechung dauer
sank von 15 14 minuten im jahr 2017 auf
10,73 minuten im jahr 20 20 hat
beispielsweise die frankfurter
allgemeine zeitung festgestellt
nächster redner und schon am pult
reinhard houben der
wirtschaftspolitische sprecher der fdp
fraktion
das habe ich ja auch schon öffentlich
sagt begrüße ist dass sie so schnell
einsteigen und ihr thema der
dekarbonisierung
sofort so schwungvoll vorgetragen haben
dadurch ist es ihnen natürlich auch
belogen heutige dem debatte etwas zu
bestimmen ich möchte da ich die ehre und
das vergnügen hatte den teil wirtschaft
im koalitionsvertrag mit zu verhandeln
doch ein bisschen wie der laut siegert
und war dass darüber hinausgehenden
koalitionsvertrages
auftreten und rufe ihnen zu ja natürlich
ist die transformation und
dekarbonisierung unserer wirtschaft eine
sehr wichtige aufgabe aber es ist nicht
das einzige
aufgabenfeld eines wirtschaftsministers
unsere wirtschaftskraft liegt an der
vielfalt der wirtschaftlichen
tätigkeiten in unserem land das beginnt
beim handwerk und mittelstand
es geht um die dienstleister natürlich
auch um die industrie und unsere
wirtschaft muss insgesamt international
wettbewerbsfähig bleiben dazu haben wir
uns ja nun auch im koalitionsvertrag der
ampel bekannt
neben preiswerte energie und
versorgungssicherheit brauchen wir
natürlich eine wirkliche bürokratie
entlastung und eben nicht nur eine
planungs beschleunigung sondern auch
eine bürokratie entlastung gerade für
den mittelstand es einfacher
es muss einfacher werden in deutschland
start ups zu gründen es muss für sie
leichter sein kapital zu akquirieren wir
müssen die berufliche ausbildung stärken
auch da ist das wirtschaftsministerium
in der verantwortung darüber hinaus ist
es wichtig dass wir in zukunft
rohstoffe für die deutsche industrie und
die deutsche wirtschaft nicht nur im
innen sondern auch im ausland sicher zur
verfügung stellen und der export ist ein
weiteres wichtiges standbein der
deutschen wirtschaft und deswegen müssen
wir uns auch mit den themen der btu und
den fragen der handelsverträge weiterhin
auseinandersetzen es gibt die
formulierung zurzeit und mercosur im
ampel koalitionsvertrag ich bitte sie
auch darauf einen blick zu werfen
darüber hinaus haben wir uns vorgenommen
möglichst einen transatlantischen
wirtschaftsraum zu schaffen eine
wichtige aufgabe und erlauben sie mir
zum schluss eine bemerkung herr minister
es ist gute tradition dass der deutschen
wirtschaftsminister auch international
ein türöffner ist für die deutsche
wirtschaft und ich erhoffe mir sehr dass
sich auch diese aufgabe wahrnehmen
vielen dank
[Applaus]
reinert open war das der
wirtschaftspolitische sprecher der
fdp-fraktion und jetzt werden sie auch
wieder eine bekannte politikerin in
einer neuen rolle sehen denn auch anja
karliczek ist ja nicht mehr ministerin
wie auch julia klöckner sondern jetzt
ist sie tourismuspolitische sprecherin
der unionsfraktion
ganz besonders auf eine branche lägen
die in diesen tagen wirklich sehr
gebeutelt ist und die von der
abstraktion mit der sie das thema
angepackt haben im moment doch nicht
viel anfangen kann
2009/10 bis 2019 war der tourismus eine
enorme erfolgsgeschichte mit
überproportionalen zuwachsraten jetzt
zweiter winter sieht die sache ganz
anders aus die zurückliegenden
weihnachts und silvester tage zeigen ein
komplett anderes bild hotels die trotz
aufwendiger hygienemaßnahmen eine viel
zu geringe auslastung von gästen
aufweisen busunternehmen der busse nicht
fahren und die ohne fahrgäste in der
garage stehen reiseveranstalter und
reisebüros die aktuell sehr stark die
zurückhaltung der kunden spüren die lage
ist alarmierend
bis zum sommer beliefen sich die
wirtschaftlichen verluste 20 21 auf ca
70 milliarden euro und um das mal in
gästen aus zu rücken damit man mal ein
gefühl dafür kriegt was das bedeutet in
dieser branche
2009 10 im vorjahr kam 90 millionen
ausländische gäste zu uns nach
deutschland
ein jahr später waren es nur noch 30
millionen ein rückgang von 66% und das
sind zahlen hinter denen sich schicksale
wirtschaftliche existenzen lebensträume
von unternehmern und ihren angestellten
verbergen und wir haben damals unter
führung der union dafür gesorgt dass
dieser porsche geholfen wurde bis heute
sind mehr als 20 milliarden euro
ausgezahlt worden
aber dieser enorm wichtigen
wirtschaftszweig braucht mittlerweile
mehr als überbrückungshilfe und
ausfallzahlungen die krise geht an die
substanz
es geht nicht mehr nur um aktuelle hilfe
die betriebe mit ihren drei millionen
beschäftigten brauchen jetzt
langfristige perspektiven und rechtliche
flexibilität im wandel denn soweit
corona geschafft es stehen genau diese
betriebe vor dem nächsten mammut
herausforderungen klimaschutz
nachhaltigkeit und digitalisierung ist
von ihnen angesprochen worden das
verändert viele geschäftsmodelle in
rasanter geschwindigkeit und deshalb
wissen jetzt alle gesetze alle
regelwerke auf den prüfstand wenn sie
nicht wollen dass ich eine ganze branche
von der zukunft verabschiedet dann
brauchen sie jetzt wieder hilfen für
modernisierung für investitionen viele
unternehmen setzen sich gerade mit der
umstellung der energieversorgung ihrer
betriebe auseinander der umbau für die
heizung eines schwimmbads oder auch die
neuausrichtung der kompletten
energieversorgung ist aufwendig es
kostet geld viel geld und geld das haben
eben diese unternehmen nach diesen
vielen schwierigen corona monaten
überhaupt nicht mehr oder denken sie an
die kleineren mittelständischen
busunternehmen es sind ja eben nicht nur
busse
in den schwarzwald oder die sächsische
schweiz die diese unternehmen machen
sondern sie sorgen auch für die
aufrechterhaltung von öffentlichen
personennahverkehr dass er funktioniert
und die unterstützung der kleinen und
mittelständischen busunternehmen dadurch
könnten sie jetzt einen beitrag leisten
für gleichwertige lebensverhältnisse
[Applaus]
in unserer heimischen großunternehmen
sorgen für mobilität und lebensqualität
im ländlichen raum und einen punkt muss
ich noch ansprechen sie haben der
tourismusbranche versprochen eine
bessere koordination der
tourismuspolitik so steht zum
koalitionsvertrag
wichtig ist jetzt erst einmal volle
aufmerksamkeit und wertschätzung für
diesen geburten wirtschaftsbereich und
dann stelle das allein für den tourismus
zuständigen beauftragten haben sie eine
koordinatorin eingesetzt die sich
gleichsam die genau so gebeutelte
maritime wirtschaft kümmern soll frau
müller ist eine nette frau aber sie kann
das definitiv nicht alles gleichzeitig
machen und noch nie sah sich die
tourismusbranche einer dramatischen
krise ausgesetzt lieber herr minister
ich denke sie sollten noch einmal in
sich gehen und der tourismuswirtschaft
einen alleinigen ansprechpartner zur
verfügung stellen mehr als 3 mio
menschen die auch eine zukunft haben
möchten haben es verdient dass die volle
aufmerksamkeit und wertschätzung der
bundesregierung erfragen
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen dieter janecek
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe frau
carlitscheck frau müller ist nicht nur
eine nette frau sie ist auch eine sehr
kompetente frau die dies sehen wir der
tourismuswirtschaft glaube ich sehr gut
bedienen wird und darauf können sie sich
verlassen
es muss ein ruck durch deutschland gehen
das war vor 25 jahren das leitmotiv
einer rede des bundespräsidenten roman
herzog zirka 500 meter von hier entfernt
im hotel adlon nun glaube ich nicht ich
war damals 21 jahre als dass sich alle
handlungsanweisungen geteilt hätte aber
die analyse von stillstand in bestimmten
bereichen und dass wir eben aufbruch
brauchen die war damals richtig und die
es heute richtig und minister habe
katers in seiner rede deutlich gemacht
wir brauchen einen aufbruch bei den
erneuerbaren energien der digital
verliebt beide innovationen
lukas grüner hat angesprochen und wir
gehen das entschlossen an und gerade bei
der energiewende geht es auch ganz
zentral um die wettbewerbsfähigkeit der
deutschen wirtschaft der deutschen
industrie wenn wir es nicht schaffen
jetzt in den nächsten jahren an tempo
zulegen dann laufen wir gefahr auch den
standort zu beschädigen das ist die
wahrheit in der afc nie verstanden
werden wird aber die industrie hat sie
längst verstanden und geht mit ihr einen
gemeinsamen weg legen
ich hatte ja die ehre in den
koalitionsverhandlungen den bereich der
innovationspolitik mitzuverhandeln
und auch dort brauchen wir neue bei den
anwendungsbezogenen innovationen ist ja
nun angedacht auch eine große agentur
ich sehe auch die kollegin anna christen
an diesem bereich
auf den weg zu bringen die dort
innovationen industrienahe aber
natürlich auch im bereich klimaschutz
forschung und entwicklung auf den markt
zu bringen so dass wir wirklich
vorankommen bei den geschäftsmodellen
die wir brauchen
wir brauchen neue weichenstellungen
nach förderungen wir brauchen
weichenstellungen auch beim thema
transfer innovation die agentur für
sprung innovation so besser ausgestattet
werden ein daten institut um auf das
thema digitalisierung in der breite
aufzustellen all das sind wichtige
themen und die stehen für aufbruch und
dafür steht diese neue koalition
ich habe mir trotzdem vorgenommen in
meinen drei minuten redezeit auch die
korona krise und die kleinen mittleren
unternehmen anzusprechen bodycheck sie
haben völlig recht das ist ein thema das
viele umtreibt und ich kann nur jeden
auffordern ermuntern auch die kümmerer
position egal ob sie in der opposition
oder der regierung jetzt mitwirken
einzunehmen was die gastronomen angeht
was aber auch die frage der
veranstaltungsbranche angeht wir führen
die gespräche die auszahlung
überbrückungshilfe vier sind jetzt
vorgezogen die laufen jetzt wir sind
hier auch auf tempo ausgerichtet wir
wissen dass wir hier eine schwierige
situation in den nächsten wochen und
monaten haben und sie können sich darauf
verlassen dass wir uns darum kümmern
wir alle hoffen dass wir nach dieser
welle in einen zustand kommen der
dauerhaft ein besserer sein wird damit
wir da auch verlässlichkeit pflegen auch
für unsere kleinen betriebe für die
selbstständigen darum wird es gehen
verlässlichkeit planungssicherheit
aufbohren dafür steht diese
ampelkoalition ich freue mich mit dabei
zu sein und komme ich auf die weitere
debatte vielen dank
sagt italiani check der
wirtschaftspolitische sprecher der
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen in einer
debatte zum
zu den vorhaben des ministeriums für
wirtschaft und klimaschutz und da haben
wir jetzt den nächsten der
bundeskanzlerin bei dieser gelegenheit
wird den plenarsaal wieder verlassen
haben eine ganze weile dieser debatte
oder ist eine ganze weile dieser debatte
gefolgt sei ein anderes zu tun hansjörg
durz ist der nächste redner und er kommt
aus der unionsfraktion
die kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen
und herren sehr geehrter herr minister
habe ich darf ihnen zunächst auch in
ihrem amt alles gute wünschen in den
vergangenen tagen haben sie eine
eröffnungsbilanz und ein sofort programm
vorgestellt beides betrag aber nur den
einen teil ihrer zuständigkeit den
klimaschutz
heute haben sie sich auch darauf
konzentriert und zumindest eine redner
der ampel hat darauf hingewiesen dass es
auch noch einen zweiten teil gibt
nämlich wirtschaft zur wirtschaftlichen
lage des landes und wie sie auf die
aktuelle situation reagieren darf war
bisher wenig von ihnen zu hören obwohl
die derzeitige wirtschaftliche lage das
durchaus erfordern würde
jedes jedes siebte unternehmen in
deutschland fühlt sich laut einer
aktuellen umfrage in seiner existenz
bedroht
die pleite der mvv haften ist nur ein
unternehmen ein beispiel bei deren
existenz eben auf dem spiel steht doch
längst nicht jede unternehmensgröße
findet den weg in die medien viele
unternehmen melden dieser tage nicht
einmal insolvenz an sondern schließen
lautlos ihre türen für immer und davon
zeugt so manche fußgängerzone wirtschaft
das sind eben nicht lustige konzerne vom
handwerker bis zum industriebetrieb vom
gründer bis zur online-plattform hier
sind mutige ideen geber und fleißige
arbeiter die unser land am laufen halten
kurzum wirtschaft das sind wir alle
wirtschaft ist gesellschaft
menschen
gehen unternehmen dieses landes arbeiten
hätten gerne von wirtschaftsminister
antworten antworten auf fragen wie diese
wie wollen sie einzelhandel gastronomie
tourismus besser durch diese schwere
zeit der pandemie helfen wann sind
lieferketten wieder ketten und nicht nur
bruchstücke wurde für die
versorgungssicherheit bei der energie
gewährleistet wie wird sturm jetzt
schnell kurzfristig wieder bezahlbar wie
bauen wir bürokratische fesseln ab gibt
es wieder einen start up beauftragten in
ihrem haus wie stehen sie zum 2 handel
doch sie habe ich bleiben bei all diesen
themen bisher weitgehend stumm die
vertreter vieler branchen hätten all
diese und noch viele mehr themen gerne
mit ihnen debattiert zb bei der üblichen
diskussion des
jahreswirtschaftsberichtes mit den
verbänden doch leider fand fanden sie
laut medienberichten für ein solches
gespräch keine zeit ich bitte sie nehmen
sie unternehmen als teil der
gesellschaft wahrnehmen sie deren sorgen
ernst und suchen sie das gespräch mit
den unternehmen
mit einem update des wettbewerbsrechts
haben wir als union in der letzten
legislatur die soziale digitale
marktwirtschaft aus der taufe gehoben
europa nimmt das update in diesen tagen
mit dem dmr vor seit jeher sind wir
zudem offen für innovationen die
ökologische aspekte in die leitplanken
der wirtschaft einfließen lassen zentral
dabei sind für uns aber
ordnungspolitische grundsätze die
funktional ismen des marktes der freie
wettbewerb nach walter eucken sind
deutlich bessere treiber von
innovationen als staatliche einzel
vorgaben je sein können innovationen die
dieses land nicht nur für den
klimaschutz zu dringend brauchen
erblicken das licht der welt nämlich
nicht auf berlin oder bonner
schreibtischen sondern in den köpfen und
werkshallen der republik vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die spd fraktion
bernd westfalen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
eine solide wirtschaft schafft
stabilität sie schafft finanziellen und
politischen
handlungsspielraum und sie sorgt für
innovation für globale herausforderung
die wir alle zusammen haben und der
klimawandel ist eins davon und deshalb
brauchen wir genau diese innovationen
aus der wirtschaft die lösungen schafft
für diese globalen probleme das geht mit
innovation mit investitionen in der
wirtschaft windräder sind nicht aus holz
geschnitzt dafür brauchen wir ein
stahlwerk dafür braucht man alle umhin
und produktion und kupfer und das werden
wir im
wirtschaftsstandort deutschland auch
weiterentwickeln was wir nicht vergessen
dürfen ist das eine insgesamt stabile
wirtschaft nur deshalb funktioniert weil
wir fleißiger arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer gut qualifiziert haben die
in drei schicht betrieb in folge und die
betrieb bei tag und nacht und am
wochenende diese leistung erwirtschaften
kontakt über den wir hier diskutieren
aber natürlich braucht es auch und
handlungsfähigen staat wir haben über
die krone hilfen gesprochen viele
wirtschaftshilfen sind auf den weg
gebracht worden von sofort helfen
überbrückungshilfen aber auch das
kurzarbeitergeld genau das ist das was
wir auf den weg gebracht haben um die
ökonomische basis in deutschland zu
sichern die sozial ökologische
marktwirtschaft
ist ein mammutprojekt
und erfordert nicht nur konsequente
politik sondern stabile
rahmenbedingungen
und einen klaren kurs damit wir den
investitions atlantis mussten wir
teilweise sehen in unternehmen auflösen
und die niedrigen zinsen die wir zurzeit
haben sind auch ein argument jetzt dafür
zu sorgen die zeit zu nutzen für
investitionen wie kann das gelingen
natürlich gehört es dafür das zu
organisieren
und wir schlagen dafür eine
transformation allianz vor wo wir die
entscheidenden akteure aus der
wirtschaft aus der politik aus der
gesellschaft mit gewerkschaften und
wissenschaft mit einbinden das
bundeskabinett hat nächste woche am 21
die klausuren minister vielleicht ist
das ja gelegenheit auch es so
übergreifen darüber zu sprechen wie man
so eine transformation allianz auf den
weg bringt und für uns als spd steht
dabei fest ein innovationsfreundliches
umfeld entsteht nur dann wenn wir auch
soziale standards mit berücksichtigen
wir brauchen ein kompass dass wir die
ökologischen ökonomischen und die
sozialen aspekte nicht aus den augen
verlieren wir brauchen dafür zb auch
tarifbindung auch mitbestimmung wir
brauchen klar beteiligung am sagen und
haben in diesem land das schafft
akzeptanz und sorgt dafür für eine
veränderung in der transparenz
erfolgreiche wirtschaftliche
modernisierung und entwicklung ist nur
dann möglich wenn wir natürlich
ausgebildete fachkräfte und
arbeitskräfte viele umsätze bleiben im
moment liegen werden nicht generiert
geschäfte weil wir zu wenig fachkräfte
haben aber natürlich auch und das setzte
den vorreden deutlich geworden brauchen
wir erneuerbare energien wasserstoff
hochlaufen wir brauchen eine
zurverfügungstellung von neuen
technologien für die wirtschaft und vor
allen dingen brauchen wir mit dem start
up unternehmen dieses innovative umfeld
was wir verknüpfen müssen mit den
industriestandorten bisheriger prägung
und vor allen dingen enorme private
investitionen die durch staatliche
flankierung abgesichert werden müssen es
gibt genug studien die der bdi zum
beispiel vorgelegt hat mit klima fade 20
die dehner leitstudie oder auch das was
alcoa aufgeschrieben hat dh es ist
machbar das was wir vorhaben werden wir
machen und ich sage nochmal auf
einrichtung afd die erneuerbaren
energien sind die zukunft die spaltung
von atomen in einem kernkraftwerk hat
auch dazu geführt dass wir eine spaltung
in der gesellschaft hatten mit spalten
kennen sie sich aus wir wollen das nicht
wir wollen den weg in eine klimaneutrale
energieerzeugung und darauf machen wir
auch uns auch auf den weg
vieles
vieles ist in den letzten jahren auf den
weg gebracht worden aber auch liegen
geblieben wir brauchen eine neue
dynamik und muss auch sagen die lage ist
zu ernst für politische spielchen und
deshalb ist es gut dass man mit bei alle
föderalen verständnis auch jetzt ein
selbstbewusstsein braucht in den
landesregierungen in der kommunalen
familie jeder landrat jede landrätin
jedem bürgermeisterin und jeder
bürgermeister gemeinderat und stadtrat
muss sich jetzt fragen welchen beitrag
kann er erbringen damit diese region in
der er lebt klimaneutral wörtern auch
das land die klimaziele erreicht das
wird die aufgabe sein die wir in den
nächsten jahren leisten müssen und
lieber herr bundesminister habe sie sind
der erste grüne wirtschaftsminister in
diesem land
ich sage ihnen die themen sind groß und
es erfordert eine mutige politik sie
können sich darauf verlassen dass die
spd fraktion mit 206 abgeordneten bis in
die haarspitzen motiviert und an ihrer
seite ist dass wir das was wir im
koalitionsvertrag verankert haben auch
durchsetzen wollen und die kann für
meine arbeitsgruppe wirtschaft sagen mit
einer hohen kompetenz und erfahrung sind
männer und frauen hier im
wirtschaftsausschuss die dazu beitragen
wollen dass die sozial ökologische
marktwirtschaft gelingt dass wir
vertrauensvoll zusammenarbeiten wollen
dich sagt das auch an die adresse der
union auch der linken sie sind herzlich
eingeladen an diesen zukunftskonzepten
mitzuarbeiten wir wollen mehr vorschrift
wagen bei allem respekt und
selbstbewusstsein sage ich immer auch
die gesetze werden nicht im ministerium
gemacht sie haben ein kompetente
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter dort in
ihrem haus aber die gesetze werden hier
beschlossen deshalb die queen an wir
sind solidarisch kritische begleitung
auf diesem weg herzlichen dank und blick
auf
das besser war das der
wirtschaftspolitische sprecher der
spd-fraktion und könnt ihr nochmal
deutlich gemacht die zusammenarbeit
willigkeit mit dem unternehmen wurde
nicht wirtschaftsminister wir sind beim
drittletzten redner in dieser debatte
angekommen und dass es andreas lenz aus
der unionsfraktion als mitglied im
ausschuss für klima schutz und energie
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren liebe ja
minister wir haben ja die tage viel über
ihre eröffnungsbilanz gehört diese hätte
aber etwas schief das zu recht auch die
faz man hat den eindruck dass bei ihnen
das transformieren der zweck ist nicht
das mittel die transformation der
gesellschaft ist aber sicher kein
selbstzweck das ist ja auch gerade herrn
hogan schon aufgefallen habe sie sind
auch wirtschaftsminister und nicht nur
transformations- minister mit wie man
meinen könnte dem schwerpunkt
transzendentale philosophie ich spreche
auch gerne über existenzielle dinge aber
bei vielen unternehmen geht es
mittlerweile um die existenz sie müssen
sich als wirtschaftsminister auch um die
probleme der unternehmen im land kümmern
und diese stöhnen unter hohen
energiekosten
es gibt natürlich kreative zerstörung
laut peter aber es gibt auch nur
zerstörung und es ist nicht unser ansatz
wir brauchen klimaschutz und eine starke
wirtschaft es ist auch und gerade hier
thema wenn betriebe schließen oder die
produktion verlagern die unternehmen die
firmen haben probleme kümmern sie sich
per haarig wir brauchen
wir brauchen eine begrenzung der energie
und stromkosten es braucht einen
stärkeren fokus auf die bezahlbarkeit
aber auch auf die versorgungssicherheit
der energie ziehen sie jedoch die
abschaffung der eeg-umlage ein jahr nach
vorne gerade jetzt braucht es
entlastungen für alle außerdem
außerdem fällt auf dass sie innerhalb
der ampel immer noch ein völlig diffus
anfällig ungeklärtes verhältnis zu 0 2
haben wir werden
wir werden gas kraftwerke brauchen lukas
kohler und andere haben sie angesprochen
da stellt sich schon die frage reichen
die anwalts im moment sind die
anforderungen der eu taxonomie hierfür
dienlich klar wollen wir gaskraftwerke
wasserstoff ready und mit kohlenstoff
angasen betreiben aber wenn durch zu
hohe anforderungen erst die kraftwerke
gebaut werden dann wird uns das auch
nichts helfen wir brauchen
versorgungssicherheit ein blackout wir
sind gott sei dank weit davon entfernt
in deutschland aber ein blackout ist
kein camping abenteuer wie das jungs vom
baby er suggeriert wurde und das
bedeutet auch dass wir eigene
kraftwerkskapazitäten im land brauchen
wir können nicht nur auf die
europäischen nachbarn uns verlassen so
wichtig der strom binnenmarkt natürlich
auch ist wir brauchen letztlich einen
massiven zubau von erneuerbaren wir
brauchen hier planungs beschleunigungen
wir brauchen aber auch eine auflösung
des konflikts zwischen artenschutz und
dem ausbau der erneuerbaren gepaart mit
akzeptanz der bevölkerung wir brauchen
innovation und technik und daran daran
werden wir sie auch messen herr minister
daran werden sie sich aber auch messen
lassen müssen es gibt eine
eröffnungsbilanz aber es gibt auch
zwischenbilanzen und es gibt letztlich
auch eine abschlussbilanz schauen wir
uns ganz genau in diesem sinne
herzlichen dank fürs zuhören
andreas lanz war das für die
unionsfraktion noch mal und wir haben
noch einen redner aus der fdp fraktion
danach noch eine rednerin aus der spd
fraktion zunächst michael grosse er ist
energiepolitischer sprecher der
fdp-fraktion seiner ersten rede im
deutschen bundestag für die fdp fraktion
hat der abgeordnete michael kruse
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
lieben kolleginnen und kollegen
insbesondere auch herr minister habeck
freue mich sehr auf die zusammenarbeit
in der künftigen
ampelkoalition als energiepolitischer
sprecher seiner fraktion kann ich sagen
der start ist geglückt und das nicht nur
im inhaltlichen weil wir uns eine ganze
menge vorgenommen haben und sie auch
diese woche gut vorgelegt haben sondern
auch in der art und weise wie wir
zusammen gefunden haben und wie wir uns
gemeinsame große projekte für dieses
land vorgenommen haben
und ich glaube dass insbesondere dieses
kleine scharmützel eben hier am rande um
die person claudia müller die ich in den
koalitionsverhandlungen habe sehr gut
kennenlernen dürfen und auch schätzen
lernen dürfen gezeigt hat dass
insbesondere der stil den diese
koalition an den tag legt ein ganz
anderer sein wird als der den die tote
letzten jahren gelebt hat und wir laden
sie herzlich ein in dieser form der
auseinandersetzung mit zu machen wir
haben es ja in den
koalitionsverhandlungen und dann auch in
den letzten wochen auch hier in der
debatte heute gesehen die energiepolitik
ist momentan der mittelpunkt der
wirtschaftspolitischen debatte und wir
haben uns große ziele gesetzt die
anhaltend hohen strompreise die im
wesentlichen
aus fossilen quellen getrieben sind
bitte sie daher noch mal ein bisschen
nachzulesen sie zeigen uns es ist genau
richtig dass wir uns auf den weg begeben
uns unabhängig zu machen von zulieferung
fossiler energie aus dem ausland und ist
eine große aufgabe für unser land aber
wer wenn ich diese koalition soll diese
aufgabe lösen meine damen und ja
wir werden neben dem mittelfristigen
ausbau der heute schon vielfach
beschrieben worden ist auch kurzfristige
maßnahmen brauchen denn insbesondere die
hohen strom- und gaspreise die hier
verschiedentlich angesprochen worden
sind natürlich werden wir uns auch
gedanken machen wie wir hier
kurzfristige maßnahmen ergreifen können
nicht nur die langfristigen maßnahmen
sind sinnvoll denn wir brauchen auch
kurzfristige ich mache mir große
gedanken wenn mich logistiker anrufen
die sagen ich habe auch auf die
förderprogramme bericht der großen
koalition noch gesetzt meine flotte
schnell umgerüstet auf gasantrieb und
ich bin in wenigen monaten insolvent
weil ich innovator war meine damen und
herren die energiewende kann nur
gelingen wenn die innovatoren wenn die
mutigen einen vorteil von ihren
pioniergeist haben und nicht wenn sie
opfer ihre eigenen entscheidungsfreude
werden
deswegen bin ich sehr froh dass die
koalition schon die ersten kurzfristigen
maßnahmen insbesondere für unternehmen
ergriffen hat die pakete der kfw war
sehr nützlich und ich lade sie alle
herzlich ein aus allen fraktionen mit
uns auf den weg zu gehen den wir
beschreiten sie alle wissen wer nicht
mit der zeit geht muss mit der zeit
gehen sie sind herzlich eingeladen auf
unseren wegen mitzukommen vielen dank
michael kruse mit seiner ersten rede im
parlament das kann man von der nächste
rednerin mich ist eine rednerin nicht
sagen nina scheer sprecherin für
klimaschutz und energie in der
spd-fraktion hat hier schon manches mal
am pult des deutschen bundestages
gestanden so auch heute allerdings
diesmal als letzte rednerin in dieser
debatte zum
ministerium für wirtschaft und
klimaschutz und dessen vorhaben in den
nächsten vier jahren
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
ich möchte auch zu beginn noch mal kurz
auf das verständnis eingehen was aus
unionsreihen nun hier herangetragen
wurde denn ist es bitter findig wenn man
feststellen muss und auch noch mal
bestätigt bekommen nach diesen acht
jahren zusammenarbeit das ein grund
missverständnis existiert in dem
verständnis von arbeit
arbeit und klimaschutz energiewende
gehören unmittelbar zusammen auch herr
lenz so sehr ich sie an schätzt als
kollege aber man kann noch nicht alles
in einer solchen debatte in der es um
ein transformationsprozess geht indessen
einer vervierfachung des ausbaus
erneuerbarer energie geht von jetzt
abgesehen eine verdopplung des 2030
dreht dann ein nebeneinander erkennen
zwischen arbeitsplätzen und dem was wir
hier im energiewende sektor zu tun nein
die arbeit führte sind dort enthalten
und genau darum geht es das ist aber das
selbstverständnis von arbeit dass es der
in der cl orientierung der politik dient
und nicht etwas
exterritoriales ist
und insofern ist es auch richtig dass
und ich bin auch dankbar wie wir und
unsere sachen robert habeck dass das
jetzt so ganz klipp und klar definiert
ist schon zu jahresbeginn ein klarer
arbeitsplan ist und mit dem in- und
anderen ja eine gute grundlage gegeben
ist dass auch tatsächlich die
ambitionierten herausforderungen die wir
einfach aus der sache heraus zu leisten
haben nämlich auch schon mit einem
muster paket schnell in die puschen zu
kommen schnell auch schon maßnahmen zu
ergreifen die auch unmittelbar wirken
können dass das eben jetzt so vor uns
liegt wir haben hier auch ich möchte ein
paar punkte einfach da rausnehmen es ist
wichtig auch ruhig wir unterstreichen
was matthias miersch gesagt habe bei dem
zwei prozent bei dem zwei prozent
flächen ziehen es ist wichtig dass wir
auch da das verständnis haben die kraft
die sich entfaltet aus anreiz uhr punkt
zu erkennen dieses wettbewerbliche
medien element dahin einzubinden dass es
auf keinen fall ein top down wird
sondern dass es einfach darauf aus der
dezentralität mit den innovationscluster
meine kollegen ubs genannt hat er neben
arbeit schaffen die instrumente sind und
so natürlich das ein selbstläufer wird
dass sie ziele nicht mehr etwas
abstraktes etwas sperriges irgendwo in
weiter ferne liegen das sind sondern
dass die ziele etwas sind was wir
wahrscheinlich locker überwinden können
sogar überrunden können wenn wir nur die
richtigen instrumente haben dass sie
dass sie diese kraft in der gesellschaft
und der wirtschaft entfalten
um die updates verteilt die haben wir
leider
teilweise verloren bei der energiewende
die muss man wieder gewinnen es geht
auch darum noch stärker die kommunen
einzubinden es geht noch stärker darum
dass anreiz und mit war für die
unternehmen gefunden werden für bürger
energie gebunden gefunden wird und es
geht natürlich auch darum die
genehmigungs henderson zu beseitigen
bürokratie-abbau im sinne von
bürokratischen hürden zu überwinden zu
leisten und es geht natürlich auch darum
in mit blick auf bayern das musste ich
einfach nochmal hervorheben die 10h
regelungen jetzt sofort sobald wie
möglich abzuschaffen
erhöhen als abstand zu definieren das
ist eine verhinderungs systematik das
ist ist einfach so das sehen sie ja auch
an den ausbau zahlen in bayern und
warten sie doch bitte nicht dass der
bundesminister zu ihnen kommt sondern
sehen sie es endlich ein schaffen sie
diese unsinnige regelung ab und ich
möchte nochmal einmal frau an frau
gestatten sie eine zwischenfrage der
fdp-fraktion nein nein ich wollte kurz
eingehen was wir generell sektor akkus
blume aus der csu dazu gesagt hat er hat
gesagt an der 10h regelung wird nicht
gerüttelt die bayerische regelung zur
windkraft sichert akzeptanz und sorgt
für bürgerbeteiligung mit verlaub herr
grube das ist lang auch wohnen denn
bürgerbeteiligung wurde in bayern
zuletzt dadurch geschaffen dass
bürgerentscheide
stattfinden bürgerentscheide sind aber
das letzte mittel was einen dann noch
bleibt wenn die landesregierung
regelungstechnische sagt windenergie
aufbau ist nicht möglich denkt sie sich
doch nur mal einmal wie absurd es wäre
wenn man zum beispiel bei der produktion
von masken oder bei der produktion von
impfstoffen eine bürger in einem
bürgerentscheid bräuchte um dort in die
in die produktion zu kommen und genau
das ist es doch auch bei der energie bei
den erneuerbaren energien hier braucht
man keine bürgerentscheide sondern hier
das selbstverständnis sein dass dort vor
ort gebaut werden kann wo wir auch die
erneuerbaren energien brauchen
und wichtig ist aber auch dass die
möglichkeiten die uns von der
europäischen seite nun an die hand
gegeben wurden mit der neuen bei
verleiht linie dass die auch
ausgeschöpft werden wir haben ja
unmittelbar die möglichkeit weiter
unterhalb also eine ausschreibung grenze
ist da definiert und unterhalb dieser
grenze auch die die den ausbau von
erneuerbaren energien zu ermöglichen das
haben wir jetzt auch die möglichkeit
gesetzliche regelungen die im lichte der
reife leitlinie vorher geschaffen wurden
jetzt noch wieder zu kassieren und die
hier auch noch viel mehr jenseits von
ausschreibungs grenzen zu ermöglichen
darauf wollte ich noch hingewiesen haben
auch mieter strom und der lösen
weitermachen speicher so weitermachen
als säule der energiewende zu etablieren
und da gehört natürlich unbedingt auf
wasserstoff dazu ich möchte noch ganz
kurz eingehen auch auf die energiepreise
natürlich ist es wichtig dass die im
zaum gehalten werden und es gibt eine
reihe von maßnahmen die auch jetzt schon
auf den weg gebracht wurden
heizkostenzuschuss wohngeld nur als
stichworte genannt weil meine zeitgleich
um ist aber es ist auch hier wichtig zu
unterstreichen der beste garant für
bezahlbare energie ist einfach der
umstieg auf erneuerbare energien die
bieten langfristig die garantie für die
bezahlbarkeit von energie und deswegen
dürfen wir auch nicht den fehler machen
in der atomenergie eine zukunft zu sehen
der deutsche weg ist richtig er ist auch
nicht nur ein deutscher weg sondern die
atomenergie ist nicht nachhaltig das ist
eine richtige und die einzig richtige
definition die man über atomenergie
finden haben deswegen lassen sie uns
auch an dieser überzeugung fest halt
vielen dank
weil die nina schiffer die letzte
rednerin eben dieser debatte über die
politik des wirtschafts- und klimaschutz
ministeriums in den kommenden jahren und
jetzt kommt doch noch mal testen der
hülse so wartet er sich doch noch einmal
vielen dank frau präsidentin dass sie
die kurzintervention zu lassen vorher
ich hätte eigentlich nur eine kurze
frage gehabt sie haben gesagt sie
möchten die 10h regel nicht das heißt
die zehnfache höher
sozusagen als entfernung ich würde von
ihnen jetzt gern wissen und ich würde es
wirklich gern wissen was sie möchten wie
weit soll oder wie groß soll der abstand
zur nächsten bebauten fläche sein also
zum nächsten haus und so weiter ich
möchte es wissen ich möchte nicht wissen
dass sie nicht sehen habe sondern ich
möchte von ihnen wissen fünf h3 h1 hat
keine ahnung es würde ich gern wissen
dann könnte und das halt verlust kraft
auch vorgeschlagen dann könnten wir
natürlich auch zb in berlin auf dem
tempelhof verdammen oder irgendwelche
parks in dem groß steht denn die sonst
ja davon nicht betroffen sind
windkraftanlagen hinbauen also wie
gesagt die frage würde ich gern von
ihnen beantwortet haben ich kann mir
vorstellen dass sie nicht beantworten
werden weil sie eher im wagen bleiben
aber vielleicht machen sich doch also
überraschen sie mich
forscher möchten sie antworten
[Applaus]
mit maske jetzt ist besser hier also die
abstandsregelung soll nach der
überzeugung der spd fraktion dass sie
dafür haben sie übrigens in den letzten
jahren hart gekämpft dass es keine fixen
abstandsregelungen gibt sie sollen am
besten nicht fix definiert werden weil
es absolut
sachfremd ist ein abstand zu definiert
ohne da die einflussfaktoren zu
berücksichtigt zu haben sondern es geht
darum dass jeweils vor ort nach den
einflussfaktoren geschaut wird die sind
immissionsschutzrechtlich da ist
natürlich wohnbebauung mit eine rolle
das sind vielleicht ein planungen
regional planungen möglich diese einzel
bezieht und darüber zu definieren wie
wir uns das miteinander der
verschiedenen nutzungen
definieren und wie wir das sortieren
aber wenn man fixe abstand zwischen
macht und wie gesagt bayern 10h regelung
ist das zehnfache der windkraftanlage
dann hat das
nichts mit nutzungskonzept zu tun
sondern ist das verhinderungsplanung und
genau das waren wir als spd nicht
und in der politik auch nicht
so nina scheer noch mal mit einer
erwiderung auf carsten also aus der fdp
fraktion zeigt die ganze sache ist doch
nicht so einfach und so schwarz weiß wie
sie bisweilen erscheinen soll